madame la ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre c'est un réel
plaisir de vous recevoir ici au Sénat
vous avez d'ailleurs siéger à nos côtés
entre 2011 et 2017
madame la secrétaire d'État nous sommes
ravis de l'opportunité de pouvoir
échanger avec vous sur les sujets
relatifs à la réalité
la sévérité de la sécheresse estivale
les incendies d'ampleur inégalés les
températures élevées de la semaine
dernière sont des symptômes du
changement climatique qui s'imposent
avec une évidence de plus en plus forte
à nos territoires et nos concitoyens la
France n'échappe pas ce phénomène
mondial tous les territoires sont
touchés le littoral avec le recul du
trait de côte la montagne avec la baisse
rectique de l'enneigement les zones
urbaines ou les canicules sont aggravés
par l'artificialisation des sols elle
est territoires agricoles qui font face
à des pertes de rendement préoccupantes
du fait notamment
d'un régime pluviométrique perturbé
l'urgence thématique impose une action
publique forte et déterminée ainsi
qu'une coordination de l'action étatique
et des territoires pour aboutir à des
résultats concrets monsieur le ministre
vous avez bien résumé la situation en
disant que le climat est un usurier plus
le temps passe plus la facture augmente
vous avez raison le taux d'intérêt
climatique et bien supérieur à celui
servi par nos banques centrales il y a
cependant une question centrale je
dirais même un défi majeur auquel les
pouvoirs publics doivent répondre le
gouvernement tout autant que le
Parlement celui de l'acceptibilité
sociale est territoriale des mesures
d'adaptation et de résilience épisode
des gilets jaunes est une mise en garde
qui pleine pour conserver une approchère
à notre commission celle du
développement durable ce cap qui
concilie l'économie le social et
l'environnement nous devons le maintenir
si nous éloignons et que nous ne
répondons pas à l'urgence climatique
nous devrons un jour choisir entre ces
trois principes et alors nous ferons
face à des nouvelles crises
face à ces défis institutionnellement
vos attributions ministérielles prennent
en compte l'indissociable le lien vous
avez parlé à juste titre d'union sacrée
entre transition énergétique et
territoire nous nous félicitons de cette
évolution
budgétairement pour 2023 les crédits
augmentent pour atteindre 40 milliards
d'euros je note en particulier la mise
en place d'un fond d'accélération de la
transition écologique de thé et de 1,5
milliards d'euros porté à 2 milliards
semble-t-il de nouvelles allocations
dont nous devons nous assurer qu'il ne
s'agit pas de redéploiement ou de
simples affichage sur la stratégie vous
prévoyez plus de concertation avec les
territoires et une contractualisation
efficace tout cela est a priori positif
et mes collègues ne manquant pas de vous
interroger pour que vous puissiez
préciser les impacts concrets sectoriels
de votre stratégie et les liens qui
unissent vos actions à celles de la
première ministre qui est chargé de la
planification écologique
avant de céder la parole à mes collègues
j'aurai quelques interrogations
préliminaires pour rembourser le débat
quel message portera la France aux
prochaines cop27 sur le climat et COP15
sur la biodiversité et quelles ambition
notre pays défendra-t-il dans les
domaines de la diplomatie climatique et
environnementale notre pays se veut un
modèle et compte jouer un rôle
exemplaire en matière de lutte et
d'adaptation changement climatique mais
aussi d'effort de préservation et de
reconquête de la biodiversité comment
capitaliser le crédit non bénéficie la
voix française dans les enceintes
internationales depuis l'accord de Paris
devons-nous essayer de compenser les
éventuels retards d'adaptation d'autres
pays ou alors les convaincre et les
aider les aider à réduire leurs
émissions
je terminerai par un sujet qui occupe
beaucoup le Sénat en ce moment avec une
mission de contrôle commune à plusieurs
commissions dédiées la stratégie du Zéro
artificialisation nette pouvez-vous nous
préciser quels sont les évolutions que
vous comptez mettre en oeuvre pour une
meilleure acceptabilité territoriale de
cette politique vous étiez notamment
engagé à recevoir la revoir les décrets
du 29 avril dernier sur la nomenclature
des sols et le calendrier de déploiement
de la réduction de l'artificialisation
dans les documents d'urbanisme ou en
sommes-nous sur ces sujets qui
préoccupent au plus haut point les élus
locaux enfin j'aurai une dernière
question plus spécifiquement pour la
secrétaire d'État chargée de la ruralité
dans le cadre d'une mission
d'information sur les perspectives de la
politique d'aménagement du territoire et
de cohésion territoriale notre
commission adopter cette année 5
rapports d'information ceci comporte de
nombreuses recommandations afin de
réduire les trop nombreuses factures
territoriales françaises
sanitaire numérique social économique de
santé et de mobilité comptez-vous vous
appuyez sur l'expertise du Sénat pour
résorber ces fractures et dépasser la
dictatomie urbain rural qui mine notre
politique d'aménagement du territoire
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie et
je vous souhaite de la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs j'aimerais vous
remercier
à double titre
pour me permettre d'avoir le bonheur de
vivre une audition à vos côtés
en espérant que ce qualificatif
continuera de s'appliquer à la fin de
cette audition au plaisir que j'y prends
à la commençant
permettez-moi d'avoir quelques espoirs
je veux dire vous commencez par vous
avez commencé par rappeler la situation
globale dans laquelle nous le trouvons
j'aime à penser qu'il faut trouver
quelques motifs d'espérance mais
peut-être que nous y reviendrons
et puis je voudrais vous remercier de me
permettre de vivre ce moment
accompagner par
Dominique Faure nous permettant d'avoir
une double audition
on m'a préparé
énormément de choses pour cette audition
quand je vois le nombre de questions que
je suis susceptible d'avoir et l'entrée
en matière du président bonjour j'ai
presque envie de sortir totalement de ce
qui a été préparé et plutôt que de vous
faire le condenser de ce qu'il y a dans
un texte budgétaire que vous êtes sur le
point d'examiner que vous êtes capable
de lire sans moi de raccourcir le la
durée de mon expression pour augmenter
le temps pendant lequel vous pourrez me
poser des questions
mais je vais peut-être d'abord insister
d'un mot sur l'architecture du ministère
dans lequel je me retrouve pour que sur
les questions de méthode vous puissiez
plus facilement sérier les sujets
1 la planification écologique a été
placée comme étant l'ambition du
président est placé à Matignon parce que
si on veut que tout le monde s'occupe de
planification écologique c'est mieux
quand c'est à Matignon qui a l'habitude
de coordonner l'action de tous les
ministères que les décisions se prennent
je précise que ça fait partie des points
sur lequel il y a un constat assez
unanime de la part des ONG ou du Haut
conseil sur le climat sur la qualité de
la gouvernance sur son architecture
avec deux ministères un de la transition
énergétique un de la transition
écologique la transition énergétique je
fais pas de dessin c'est le sujet sur
lequel compte tenu de l'actualité depuis
le 24 février nous avons des occasions
de passer du temps j'ai vu que certains
d'entre vous avais des questions
éventuelles sur le nucléaire ou sur des
sujets de ce type je ne suis pas certain
puisque ça n'est pas dans notre
périmètre ministériel si les questions
seront trop précises de pouvoir
totalement satisfaire votre curiosité si
nous sortons des grands principes
nous au sein du ministère de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires nous avons en direct le
logement et les transports et c'est
heureux puisqu'il s'agit de deux
secteurs qui a E2 contribuent environ à
50% de nos émissions donc au moment où
on mène une politique d'atténuation ou
d'adaptation au changement climatique
c'est bien d'avoir la main en direct sur
ce type de responsabilité
bien entendu les questions d'écologie au
sens large de préservation et de
protection de la biodiversité et puis
cette particularité d'avoir la cohésion
des territoires à l'intérieur du pôle
sur les six ministres du pôle 4 ont été
maire
et deux ont été sénateurs
je pense que vous pouvez goûter à juste
titre le fait que dans ce casting
et dans cette architecture il y a deux
messages le premier c'est que nous ne
réussirons pas la cohésion des
territoires sans les élus locaux
parce que la vérité c'est que vous
pouvez prendre toutes les mesures que
vous voulez pour expliquer qu'on va
décarboner les transports
quel que soit votre plan vélo il faut
ensuite des mers qui sont volontaires
qui conduisent les concertations
nécessaires pour réaliser les pistes
cyclables sécurisées vous pouvez appeler
de vos voeux en déplacement des
transports en commun mais il faut une
autorité organisatrice des mobilités qui
est ensuite en capacité de les décider
vous pouvez décider de d'être sobre sur
le plan du foncier mais c'est pas le
ministre qui signe les permis de
construire les scottes et les pluies
doivent se faire aussi en s'appuyant sur
la totalité de ceux qui au quotidien
sont l'échelon de proximité de notre
République et ça me permet de faire le
lien avec ce que vous disiez monsieur le
président
on conduira cette transition encore
moins contre les gens
et si
on oublie
l'acceptabilité sociale le caractère
solidaire de la transition on pourra se
donner tous les objectifs qu'on veut la
vérité c'est qu'on les atteindra pas
je vous renvoie à un maire qui parce
qu'il aurait des ambitions extrêmement
fortes en matière
d'économie circulaire déciderait de
demander aux gens d'avoir un tri
sélectif avec 5 ou 6 sortes de poubelles
si l'explique pas s'il donne pas la
finalité et si des gens n'appliquent pas
les consignes c'est du gaspillage
d'argent public parce que vous avez mis
en place un système de collecte que
personne n'utilise il faut donc être
capable d'envoyer une impulsion
d'assumer une ligne avec une ambition
parce qu'on doit doubler le rythme de la
baisse de nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et dans le même temps toujours
se demander comment l'écologie est
capable de nous embarquer tous ensemble
et pas d'être un alibi pour restaurer la
lutte des classes ou un moyen qui
consiste à essayer de défendre
des comportements qui desservent la
cause
quand je vous aurais dit ça avant de
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
aurez j'attire simplement votre
attention sur deux chiffres
et le reste ce sera pour vous répondre
le premier
c'est le fait que jamais le budget de la
transition écologique n'avait autant
augmenté et pas grâce à du recyclage de
crédit j'aurai l'occasion de répondre de
manière très précise on est bien sûr des
crédits nouveaux et je vous donne le
fond de ma pensée c'est bien mais ça ne
suffira pas
parce que le coût et les investissements
dont on a besoin en particulier dans les
transports et dans le ferroviaire
nécessiteront des ambitions qui pour le
moment ne figurent pas dans les 600
millions d'euros complémentaires qu'on a
ajouté pour une raison simple c'est que
nous avons décidé d'attendre la copie du
comité d'orientation des infrastructures
comités auxquelles le Sénat a été
associé qui après avoir fait le tour de
toutes les régions préfecture et
conseils régionaux et censés recenser
les grandes infrastructures sur
lesquelles il y a des besoins et donc
déterminer le niveau de trajectoire dont
on a besoin
le deuxième chiffre c'est 0
comme le nombre d'agents qui vont
quitter ce ministère dans les 5 ans
l'écologie le pôle écologique est celui
qui depuis 20 ans a le plus contribué en
pourcentage à la baisse des effectifs de
la fonction publique d'État en moyenne
1000 agents par an
et c'est une moyenne
et cette moyenne elle a été métronomique
elle a valu sous tous les gouvernements
et sous toutes les couleurs politiques
pour la première fois
il y a un coup d'arrêt et des
recréations de poste puisque mon pôle
ministériel sera intégralement stabilisé
et à l'intérieur la Société du Grand
Paris va rendre des centaines de postes
sur la période conformément à sa fin de
mission qui nous permettront d'accentuer
les redéploiements notamment vers des
opérateurs qui en ont besoin et donc
indépendamment des postes que nous
recréons et des
pentes que nous inversons
pour Météo France pour l'Office français
de la biodiversité pour l'ADEME et pour
des quantités d'autres il y aura
d'autres perspectives l’onf n'est pas
dans le périmètre ministériel de la
transition écologique la confusion est
assez légitime parce que ça pourrait
tout à fait être chez nous la
préservation de la nature et le rôle de
captation de carbone c'est chez nous
mais la sylviculture c'est à
l'agriculture et la répartition fait que
les crédits de l'ONF
sont au sein du ministère de
l'Agriculture même s'il y a une forme de
coachute elle et que ce sont évidemment
des sujets sur lesquels nous travaillons
de manière étroite voilà les quelques
points d'entrée que je pouvais vous
indiquer et quand nous entamerons les
réponses aux questions je vous répondrai
sur la diplomatie climatique et sur le
zan avec plaisir président merci
Monsieur Miss madame secrétaire d'État
merci monsieur le Président donc
quelques mots pour vous dire tout le
bonheur qui est le mien de faire partie
de ce pôle que Christophe Béchu vient de
décrire et de dire à quel point les
ruralité
doivent ancrer cette transition
écologique et à quel point on a un rôle
à jouer vous êtes aux côtés de nos mères
ruraux vous savez à quel point je suis
proche aussi de nos élus locaux j'en
suis à ma 18e visite officielle depuis
mi-juillet l'idée c'est d'écouter les
élus locaux c'est d'écouter les
associations c'est d'écouter les
socioprofessionnelles c'est essayer de
comprendre
en quoi rural qui a été voté en
septembre 2019 3 milliards d'euros
injectés 180 une mesure en quoi cet
agenda rural a été bénéfique sur tel ou
tel sujet la première ministre nous a
laissé jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour
analyser les bienfaits de cet argent qui
a été injecté sur nos territoires et
porter un second souffle ensemble avec
vous pour quoi on semble avec vous parce
que je consulte beaucoup de
parlementaires beaucoup d'élus locaux
dans le cadre de plusieurs groupes de
travail concomitant au 5 du CNR qui ont
tous une composante ruralité pour
essayer d'élaborer ce que pourrait être
une feuille de route début 2023 que nous
présenterons à la première ministre
alors les sujets sur lesquels vous allez
nous interroger et qui manient et
m'occupe tous les jours vous allez pas
être surpris c'est évidemment
nos intérêts c'est évidemment
Lausanne c'est évidemment nos déserts
médicaux c'est évidemment l'écoute
d'énergie
dans notre territoire de campagne et de
montagne c'est l'accès aux services
publics et donc au numérique c'est
l'accès à l'emploi l'attractivité tous
ces sujets sont au cœur des
consultations et des concertations que
je conduis vous avez compris que ce
portefeuille ministériel il est
passionnant entre autres parce qu'il est
extrêmement transversal pour tout ce qui
est des aires médicaux c'est évidemment
travailler maintenant la main avec Agnès
Firmin le Bodo pour tout ce qui est
accès au numérique accès aux services
publics c'est travailler avec Stanislas
Guérini et donc il y a un certain nombre
de sujets que je porte en propre au sein
du pôle mais il y a un certain de sujets
que je conduis en transversalité avec
mes collègues et ça en fait moi je
trouve tout l'intérêt donc je voulais
juste vous dire que j'étais dans cette
phase de concertation de consultation de
travail et vous dire que sur le sujet
des edrr vous serez pas surpris
d'entendre que je travaille avec le
sénateur delcro et que
je suis tout à fait ouverte puisque nous
allons organiser une réunion d'ici
on va dire une petite quinzaine de jours
avec les sénateurs qui le souhaitent sur
le sujet des adrr dire aussi
parce que vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président
que ma volonté totale de m'appuyer sur
les 5 rapports que vous avez cités que
j'ai lu et qui nourrissent les
réflexions que nous conduisons au sein
du pôle sur le sujet des ruralité
merci
Monsieur ministre merci madame monsieur
cratère d'état vous avez bien fait de
raccourcir vos propos liminaires
puisqu'il est 24 demandes de parole
alors je vais
24 alors je vais dans un premier temps
oui alors je vais donner la parole aux
rapporteur pour avis sur le PLF 2023 et
pour ne pas
me tromper j'espère que je ne vais pas
me tromper je vais les donner ces prises
de parole par ordre alphabétique donc je
vais commencer par Monsieur Chevrollier
merci monsieur le Président
de la ministre monsieur le ministre
pour faire vite le président l'évoqué
l'été dernier a été marqué par une
sécheresse importante donc je voudrais
aborder la place centrale de la question
de l'eau dans notre pays puis pourtant
tempéré avec les événements aussi du
week-end dernier mais Monsieur le
Ministre on a parlé lors des la séance
des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement donc il y a beaucoup de
conflits d'usage autour de l'eau
pourtant ces sujets ont été abordés sous
le précédent quinquennat dans le cadre
des Assises de l'eau dans le cadre du
varen agricole de l'eau et de
l'adaptation au changement climatique et
pourtant encore aujourd'hui plus d'une
centaine de communes n'ont pas été en
mesure de distribuer de l'eau potable à
leurs habitants cet été
et l'Union des Industries entreprises de
l'eau à chiffrer à 4,6 milliards d'euros
le déficit annuel d'investissement pour
le petit cycle de l'eau donc en tant que
rapporteur budgétaire sur les crédits
relatifs à l'eau j'aimerais connaître
les mesures que compte prendre le
gouvernement pour améliorer la gestion
de l'eau en France comptez-vous élaborer
une nouvelle loi sur l'eau ou porter un
plan Marshall pour accroître la
résilience hydrique de notre pays et à
ce titre les 900 000 euros qui sont dans
le projet de loi de finances pour la
déclinaison opérationnelle du varen
laisse quelque peu perplexes les agences
de haut quant à elles ont obtenu 100
millions d'euros supplémentaires de
moyens mais elle souhaiterait pourquoi
pas avoir la suppression du du plafond
mordant les besoins pour le petit cycle
de l'eau comme pour le grand cycle de
l'eau sont extrêmement importants
et j'avais une deuxième question
m'intéressant à l'air et
particulièrement à la pollution de l'air
là aussi le ministre on a parlé tout à
l'heure vous savez le Conseil d'État
mois dernier à sanctionner l'État
français comme quoi une garantissait pas
suffisamment l'amélioration de la
qualité de l'air dans les délais
suffisant et donc il y a eu une
astreinte de 10 millions d'euros donc le
coût humain et économique de la
pollution atmosphérique est importante
c'est un enjeu de santé publique de
première importance donc là aussi
comment le gouvernement souhaite agir
pour accentuer les efforts de la France
pour qu'on ne soit plus condamné et puis
pour améliorer la qualité de l'air de
nos compatriotes en zone urbaine comme
dans les territoires ruraux je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur je vais
donner la parole à tous les rapporteurs
pour avis ils sont 8 et après vous
pourrez répondre monsieur gilet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur et
Madame la Ministre
alors nous le savons donc la
décarbonation du transport routier c'est
un enjeu essentiel puisque c'est le mode
le plus émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
du secteur des transports qui lui-même
le secteur le plus émetteur donc en
France donc plusieurs questions sur ce
sujet mais la première question pour
porte sur l'adaptation des véhicules aux
besoins de transport en tant que
rapporteur pour avis sur les crédits du
PLF pour 2023 relatif au transport
routier j'ai eu l'occasion d'entendre
des chercheurs mais aussi des
représentants des constructeurs sur la
question des gabarits des véhicules
neufs mises à la vente en effet si dans
les années 1960 le poids moyen d'un
véhicule automobile s'élevé à 800 kg il
attend aujourd'hui une tonne 2 de sorte
que la voiture transporte à 92% son
propre poids ce qui est quand même un
sujet vraiment particulier donc dans le
contexte actuel il semblerait opportun
d'encourager le développement de ce
qu'on appelle les véhicules
intermédiaires pour bon nombre de
déplacements puisque vous savez que les
déplacements
travail domicile sont inférieurs en
moyenne à 15 km déplacement quotidiens
c'est inférieur à 40 de toute façon donc
ces véhicules intermédiaires pourraient
être avoir un intérêt vraiment
particulier mais pour autant d'après les
constructeurs le risque serait de voir
se développer une importation massive de
ces véhicules qui ne sont du moins pour
l'heure que rarement produit en France
ou en Europe et donc là un risque de
concurrence d'un côté on produit des
véhicules très lourds en France avec une
plus-value mais on n'a pas de filière
qui produisent des véhicules
intermédiaires donc d'après vous comment
résoudre cette équation et encourager le
développement de véhicules plus légers
quel bilan tirez-vous de la première
année de mise en oeuvre du malus au
poids c'est que c'est un sujet qui est
particulièrement sensible notamment pour
la filière mais qui est un enjeu
deuxième question sur le déploiement des
zones à un faible émission de mobilité
vous mettez en valeur le prêt à taux
zéro pour l'acquisition de véhicules
propres pour les personnes physiques et
morales il faut bien le souligner
puisqu'il y a un enjeu également sur les
personnes morales domiciliées dans ou à
proximité d'une Z et des feux c'était
l'objet d'ailleurs d'une négociation
particulièrement serrée avec le
rapporteur du texte climat et violence
donc Philippe Tabarro il faut le
rappeler pour autant il
excellent pour autant il semble que les
modalités retenus dans le décret
d'application sont assez restrictives
comme le niveau du foyer fiscal de
référence retenue ou encore l'obligation
des domiciliés ou de justifier d'une
activité professionnelle au sein de la
ZDE alors que la loi retenait simplement
le critère de domiciliation à proximité
afin d'accompagner le plus grand nombre
de concitoyens dans le déploiement des
et des feux ne pourrait-on pas envisager
d'assouplir ces critères par ailleurs
pouvez-vous faire le point sur le
déploiement de la lecture automatisé des
plaques d'immatriculation qui est une
condition clé de la bonne mise en œuvre
dès ses défauts alors vous avez réuni
donc le premier comité interministériel
sur le sujet donc il y a certains
enseignements que vous vous tirez bien
sûr concernant ces réunions et vous
semblez miser beaucoup sur la mise en
place des comités de suivi mais il
faudra bien sûr des agilités en termes
de politique pour accompagner les
remarques éventuelles que les com mettre
en place pour travailler l'acceptabilité
de ce sujet est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser vos orientations la matière je
vous remercie c'est chers collègues j'ai
donné la parole à Jean-Michel Houlgate
concerne au premier plan puisque vous
êtes chargé de la transition numérique
des territoires le développement des
réseaux numériques à travers le plan
France très haut débit et le New Deal
mobile relève certes de la compétence de
Jean-Noël Barrault qui est ministre de
la transition numérique mais je
souhaitais cependant vous interroger sur
deux points qui intéressent directement
les territoires le premier s'agissant
d'une New Deal mobile les remontées de
terrain font état d'un problème qui
devient récurrent à savoir certains
opérateurs
profite de l'arrivée à échéance de
nombreux beaux relatifs aux antennes
mobiles pour racheter les
infrastructures et imposer ensuite aux
opérateurs de télécommunication un loyer
très élevé le risque est alors de faire
fuir les opérateurs et de créer des
trous de couverture et même de réouvrir
si on peut dire des zones blanches s'il
souhaite remettre en cause ses
conventions les mers se trouvent eux
obligés de verser des sommes importantes
à l'opérateur d'infrastructures pouvant
atteindre des dizaines de milliers
d'euros votre ministère a-t-il eu des
remontées sur ce phénomène et quelle
mesure pourriez-vous prendre pour les
juguler et mieux aviser les mers sur ces
pratiques deuxième point je souhaiterais
aussi vous interroger sur le guichet
cohésion numérique des territoires qui
est piloté par la NCT en avril dernier
le gouvernement a acté le prolongement
de ses dispositifs destinés à apporter
un soutien financier au ménage qui ne
bénéficient pas d'un débit internet
suffisant afin qu'il se dotent
technologies sans fil ou hertzienne
alternatives à la fibre que ce soit le
satellite la boucle locale radio ou la
4G fixe jusqu'à présent l'enveloppe de
ce guichet était largement consommé 1,7
millions d'euros avait été déployé en
fin d'année dernière sur une enveloppe
prévue de 100 millions d'euros alors que
les besoins sont réels où en est-on du
déploiement de ce dispositif de même les
opérateurs nous ont alerté sur la
situation de certains clients qui bien
qu'ils soient raccordables ne peuvent
être raccordés à la fibre sans effectuer
au préalable des travaux sur leur
domaine privé par exemple en matière de
génie civile or le coût de ces travaux
peut être dissuasif serait-il
envisageable même si j'imagine que c'est
juridiquement complexe d'étendre le
périmètre du guichet cohésion numérique
des territoires pour faciliter ses
raccordements et réduire ainsi le risque
à charge de ces menaces je vous en
remercie
merci chers collègues je vais dans la
parole à Frédéric marchand merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en tant que rapporteur pour
avis des crédits relatifs à la recherche
dans les domaines de l'énergie du
développement et de la mobilité durable
je souhaite vous interroger sur le
soutien à la recherche en matière de
transition écologique prévue par le PLF
pour 2023 celui-ci constitue un
préalable indispensable à la mise en
oeuvre d'une transition écologique et
énergétique juste et efficace les
travaux menés par les opérateurs de ce
programme qu'il s'agit du commissariat
l'énergie atomique et aux énergies
alternatives de l'Institut de
Radioprotection et de la sûreté
nucléaire ou encore de l'université
Gustave Eiffel pour ne citer que éclair
sur les choix de demain afin d'atténuer
le changement climatique l'enveloppe de
ces crédits connaît une augmentation de
72 millions d'euros environ ce que je
salue néanmoins ce budget ne parviendra
à priori pas à compenser les surcoulis à
la hausse des prix de l'énergie auxquels
vont être confrontés ces organismes de
recherche ce qui est bien évidemment
susceptible de menacer la continuité de
leurs travaux à titre d'illustration la
facture énergétique du CEA qui 70
millions d'euros pourraient être
multipliés par 3 pour atteindre 210
millions d'euros autre point d’alerte la
subvention accordée à l'Institut polaire
français Paul-Émile Victor qui sera sans
doute insuffisante pour lui permettre de
conduire ces opérations comme prévues or
les services rendus par l'IPF sont
indispensables au maintien de la
recherche polaire qui comme nous le
savons tous est essentiel pour mieux
comprendre le changement climatique j'ai
bien conscience que cette question
relève davantage du ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche mais d'après vous comment
permettre à ces opérateurs de faire face
et de mener à bien l'ensemble de leurs
travaux de recherche je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je vais bien la
parole à Pascal Martin merci monsieur le
président madame et monsieur le ministre
je souhaiterais vous interroger sur deux
sujets principaux intéressants la
thématique de la prévention des risques
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne les
effectifs de l'inspection des
installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement les ICPE
et d'autre part la prise en compte du
nouveau programme nucléaire français
exclusivement et j'ai bien entendu
votre précision monsieur le ministre
dans la politique de prévention des
risques sans évoquer la politique
nucléaire à proprement parler qui ne
relève pas du périmètre de votre
ministère comme vous le savez à la suite
de l'incendie majeur des usines
lubrisoles et Normandie logistique à
Rouen le gouvernement avait annoncé une
augmentation de 50 postes sur deux ans
pour les inspections des ICPE poste qui
sont placés dans les DREAL nous avons
donc 1272 ETP budgétés
toutefois si je salue cette annonce
budgétaire et cette promesse tenue il
semble que cette volonté a du mal à se
traduire dans les faits avec
d'importantes vacances de postes dans
les Dréal sur ces sur ces postes et un
manque d'attractivité pour ses fonctions
dans les réponses aux questionnaires
budgétaires rédigés par vos services il
est indiqué fin 2020 il y avait
1557 agents techniques affectés au
service des au sein pardon des services
déconcentrés sur cette politique début
2022 vos services monsieur le ministre
indiquent qu'il n'y avait plus que
1529 agents techniques donc au lieu d'un
renforcement des effectifs on assiste à
une érosion de 28 postes qui annule donc
les annonces du gouvernement cette
situation m'inquiète car depuis trois
ans le ministère a donné des
instructions renforcées au service qui
ne pourront donc pas s'appliquer faute
de moyens
pour être très franc nous avons du mal à
y voir clair sur la question des
vacances de postes et quand nous
interrogeons le secrétariat général du
ministère de la transition écologique il
nous est répondu qu'il est impossible de
connaître le taux de vacances DREAL par
Dream alors je vous pose sur le ministre
la question suivante quel est le taux de
vacances des postes d'inspecteur des
icepe dans les Dréal et quels seront les
effectifs réels de l'inspection des ICPE
pour 2023
autre point qui est lié à ce sujet c'est
le nombre de contrôles des ICPE après
l'événement de Rouen le gouvernement
avait annoncé une augmentation de 50%
des contrôles d'ici demain 22 ce qui
correspondait à 27 300 visites annuelles
or l'an passé seul 22000 inspections ont
été réalisées d'autant plus que pour
atteindre ces chiffres certaines
inspections sont allégées
cette année vos services indiquent que
l'objectif de 27000 visites a été
repoussées à 2023 je cite en raison des
circonstances exceptionnelles dues à la
crise sanitaire et des difficultés liées
aux vacances de poste ma question là je
pense est encore assez simple
pouvez-vous nous expliquer les raisons
et que comptez-vous faire face à cette
situation
je poursuis avec la question du nouveau
programme nucléaire la Commission
nationale du débat public dont nous
avons reçu la présidence Chantal
Jouanneau il y a quelques jours va
prochainement lancer une grande
concertation sur le sujet
pouvez-vous revenir sur très brièvement
l'organisation de cette concertation
son calendrier le cadre qui a été fixé
d'une manière plus générale les moyens
de la CNDP vous semble-t-il en phase
avec les enjeux actuels de la démocratie
environnementale dont nous percevons
tout l'intérêt alors que nous nous
apprêtons examinés ce soir même le
projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables j'en termine avec
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire il s'agit
du programme 180 mission écologie le
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
prévoit un léger rehaussement des moyens
de l'autorité que je salue avec un
plafond d'emploi à 457 emploi fixe
contre 445 l'an passé toutefois ces
moyens humains me semblent encore
insuffisants par rapport aux enjeux
énormes qui sont face à nous
quelle vision monsieur ministre
avez-vous du rôle de votre ministère
dans le lancement de ce nouveau
programme nucléaire et quel serait le
rôle de votre ministère dans le cadre du
projet de loi qui sera prochainement
déposé au Parlement
enfin pouvez-vous nous engager sur une
trajectoire d'augmentation des effectifs
de
l'ASN dans les prochaines années je vous
remercie
si chers collègue je vais dans la parole
à Louis Jean de Nicolas
en ce qui concerne les collectivités
territoriales donc les programmes
11279 et 162 nous avons largement parlé
avec madame Caroline cailleux la semaine
dernière donc
je ne reviendrai pas dessus sur les
financements mais je voudrais simplement
vous poser quatre questions tout d'abord
nous allons parler ce matin dans une
autre réunion de la NCT nous arrivons au
terme des trois ans de fonctionnement
qui altéré il faut le dire par la
période de confinement qu'en est-il
selon vous du bilan de cette agence à
tel maintenant sa vitesse de croisière
va-t-elle être étendue ou en ce qui
concerne et en ce qui concerne les
contrats d'objectifs et de performance
qui doit être revisité il y aura-t-il
évaluation et cette évaluation se
fera-t-elle dire uniquement avec les
services de l'État où les collectivités
locales départements région et maire
seront-ils associés deuxième question
en ce qui concerne les deux TR est
spécialement la décile pour lequel les
parlementaires n'ont pas leur mot à dire
sur les attributions de crédits par les
préfets
est-ce qu'il y a eu des incitations à
encourager la sobriété énergétique ou
les investissements d'énergie
renouvelables dans les communes
troisième question des politiques
publiques ont été mises en place tel
qu'action cœur de ville les petites
villes de demain les mers sont en
attente de garanties de financement pour
jusqu'en 2026 la fin de leur mandat et
cela est prévu et pour ne pas oublier la
secrétaire d'État de petites questions
aussi quid de l'agenda rural pour 2023
quelles sont les politiques qui sont
prévues dans ce cadre-là et quid des et
derrière qui font l'objet de nombreux
rapports et qui est que pour lequel tout
le monde attend qu'elle soit
véritablement définie
si la parole de Évelyne Perrot merci
président monsieur le ministre je suis
rapporteur pour avis du budget de
l'aviation civile j'ai deux petites
questions pour desenclaver nos
territoires que pensez-vous de l'idée de
développer des trajets aériens à la
demande avec des petits avions les plus
décarbonés possible plutôt que de
développer des lignes aériennes
régulières peu fréquenter ou trop
déficitaire je fais ici référence à
l'idée que l'avion électrique ou à
hydrogène pourrait devenir le transport
le plus propre en prenant en compte le
fait qu'il ne nécessite qu'une
infrastructure minimale au sol
deuxième question sur le thème en vogue
des jets privés et plus précisément de
l'aviation non commerciale pouvez-vous
rappeler les tenants et les aboutissants
de la mesure adoptée par les députés sur
l'augmentation des taxes sur les
carburants d'aviation qui est concerné
et quel sera l'impact de cette mesure
merci beaucoup
et enfin Philippe Tabarro
monsieur le Président encore oui
monsieur le ministre secrétaire d'État
sur le transport Ferret ferroviaire
fluvial et maritime puisque j'ai la
l'honneur de rapporter ces budgets et
j'aimerais parler plus particulièrement
également parce que vous connaissez bien
ces sujets vous avez été un excellent
président de l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport alors pour
revenir sur ce projet de budget 2023 je
dois dire que nous attendions mieux et
surtout plus pour soutenir le
développement de du transport
ferroviaire et du et du transport
fluvial pour ce qui concerne le
ferroviaire lorsque j'ai interrogé le
ministre chargé des transports sur la
ventilation de l'augmentation de
l'enveloppe consacrée aux
infrastructures de transport il a
indiqué qu'environ 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seraient affectés au
réseau ferroviaire en 23 pour parler
concrètement et après avoir les
documents budgétaires il apparaît que
c'est 150 millions d'euros permettront
de mener des opérations de régénération
du réseau sur environ 90 km
supplémentaires quand la longueur de
notre réseau est d'environ 29000 km
d'après vous ce coup de pouce parce que
vous comprendrez qu'il nous est
impossible de parler ici de relance ou
de soutien massif permettra-t-il
vraiment de tenir nos objectifs
ambitieux
concernant ce mode de transport j'ai
bien noté également
que à l'Assemblée nationale un certain
nombre de nos collègues avaient adopté
un amendement visant à bomber le soutien
aux transports ferroviaire à la hauteur
de 3 milliards et je me demande quelle
suite lui sera réservé et puis pour
terminer sur ce sujet du ferroviaire
monsieur le ministre essayer de vous
engager s'il vous plaît sur une loi
d'investissement pluriannuel
vous allez encore me parler du coi j'en
fais partie le COI a bien travaillé
continué à travailler va encore
travailler faire des propositions mais
au bout d'un certain temps c'est à cette
politique de prendre la décision et de
mettre des sommes face à un certain
nombre de d'investissements qui sont
indispensables et permettez-nous de
douter de ça par rapport au contrat de
performance le contrat de performance à
refroidit
nos voilà tout ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
de positif avec votre arrivée avec
l'envie de faire du ferroviaire une
priorité tant qu'on aura ce contrat de
performance à cette hauteur et qu'on
leur a pas révisé est tant qu'on n'aura
pas une loi pluriannuelle sur le
transport on ne pourra pas avancer on
n'arrivera pas à vous croire ni à croire
le ministre bonne concernant voie
navigable de France
un petit sujet aussi et c'est un combat
qu'on partage avec ma collègue Martine
filleul
on salue l'augmentation des fonds qui
sont alloués au transport fluvial est-ce
que vous faites pour VNF au niveau des
investissements par contre chaque année
on réduit les ETP sur VNF alors c'est
pas quelque chose qui me choque
voilà que qu'on puisse dans certains
administrations en général voire
peut-être redéployer du personnel dans
des secteurs qui en auraient le plus
besoin mais là sur VNF on a l'impression
que ça tombe chaque année sur eux c'est
quand en 2020 92 EDP en 2021 99tp en 22
30 en 23 40 alors là je me pose la
question certes je sais qu'il y a une
modernisation qui va permettre de
pouvoir
supprimer certaines voilà la présence
physique sur certains endroit mais comme
mais quand même quand c'est un nombre
aussi important soit est-ce que je ne
pense pas les gens de VNF ne
travaillaient pas suffisamment et on se
la coulé douce à VNF mais je veux pas
penser ça et je me dis que peut-être les
restrictions qui sont demandées au
niveau du personnel au niveau de VNF
sont un peu excessives même si je
comprends ce que vous avez souhaité
impulser au niveau de de nos politiques
publiques voilà Monsieur le Ministre
j'en ai déjà trop dit merci de votre
écoute bien cette première série de
questions et rapporteurs pour avis est
terminé pour vous rassurer il y a encore
bien encore 17 demande de parole
OK
donc chacun comprendra que je fasse des
réponses courtes et de pas entrer parce
que rien que sur le zan je pense qu'on
est capable collectivement d'y passer 30
minutes pour essayer de d'indiquer les
points sur lequel nous pourrions avancer
je vais me contenter de poser les têtes
de chapitres votre première question
monsieur le Président elle était sur la
question de la diplomatie
environnementale et pas n'importe quel
moment puisque nous avons un
enchaînement en novembre puis en
décembre de la COP 27 sur le climat et
de la COP 15 sur la biodiversité
ce sont des rendez-vous qui sont
d'autant plus cruciaux que la diplomatie
est indispensable dans tous les domaines
et quand les décisions que nous prenons
des impacts sur nos voisins elle les
d'autant plus et il y a peu de domaines
autant que les questions climatiques
dont nous sommes totalement
interdépendants
le monde continue à augmenter ses
émissions gaz à effet de serre
tous les rapports montrent que
l'accord de Paris puis ce qui a pu être
dit à Glasgow sont en passe d'appartenir
au passé aux oubliettes s'il n'y a pas
un sursaut
le covid avait offert un répit avec une
baisse des émissions qui était liée au
covid mais la reprise se fait à
l'échelle mondiale à un niveau supérieur
à ce qui était les émissions avant covid
au milieu de tout ça il y a un continent
qui a commencé à baisser ses émissions
c'est le nôtre
et donc nous allons acharmer le Cher
fort d'avoir commencé à baisser nos
émissions mais sans trop non plus si
vous voulez faire de
donner de leçons d'abord parce que nous
sommes un club de pays qui a grandement
contribué au réchauffement si on prend
la totalité de notre histoire et d'autre
part parce que même nous nous ne sommes
pas au rythme auquel nous devrions être
pour tenir les objectifs de
décarbonation de 55% de nos émissions à
l'horizon 2030 et donc je ne parle pas
de la neutralité carbone 2050
la ligne de la France c'est la ligne du
keep je vais le faire en français
gardons l'objectif de 1,5 degrés vivant
cette ligne là c'est celle qui rappelle
à tout le monde la nécessité d'agir et
d'ajouter des ambitions aux ambitions et
en tout cas de crédibiliser les
stratégies de décarbonation j'attire
votre attention sur le fait que par
exemple les mesures prises sur les
moteurs thermiques en 2035 sont un des
éléments de crédibilité de la feuille de
route de l'Union européenne en ce qui
concerne la diminution de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
j'ajoute que dans le budget qui vous est
présenté ça ne coûte pas d'argent mais
c'est un impact considérable c'est la
suppression de la garantie que la Coface
pouvait apporter dans le cadre
d'opération
visant à trouver de nouveaux gisements
d'énergie fossiles on avait arrêté de
les subventionner mais via la Coface on
pouvait encore garantir des travaux de
ce type désormais nous n'aurons plus de
liens entre le gouvernement et tout
opération qui relèverait des énergies
fossiles je vais pas avoir le temps
d'aller beaucoup plus loin mais voilà
globalement la ligne sur laquelle nous
sommes acharmé le Cher nous allons
profiter de la journée du 16 ou du 17
pour faire un temps spécial biodiversité
pour se donner une chance
d'augmenter notre degré de concertation
et d'accord en vue de la COP 15 à
Montréal qui ne se présente pas sous les
meilleurs auspices
cette COP15 elle est cruciale autant
pour la cop27 vous avez un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui vous disent que
après Paris après Glasgow en le faisant
en Égypte dans ce contexte au moment de
la reprise avec la guerre on aura sans
doute plutôt une coop de transition
qu'une coque d'engagement autant la COP
15 sur les espèces menacées elle est
d'autant plus importante que ça fait des
années que nous l'avons en point de mire
nous notre ambition c'est de sortir de
ça avec des objectifs qui soient
mesurables
qui soit quantifiable et avec un
calendrier là où c'est assez facile de
se dire qu'on est d'accord sur les
ambitions ça l'est beaucoup plus quand
on commence à discuter la France avec le
Costa Rica anime une coalition qui est
la Coalition pour une haute ambition
nous sommes 105 pays à la minute nous
parlons et nous défendons pour faire
simple la règle des 30-30 c'est-à-dire
30 % des terres 30% des mers à l'horizon
2030 qui ferait l'objet d'une
préservation on se heurte à l'hostilité
de certains pays dont la Chine qui
préside cette COP puisque même si elle a
lieu au Canada elle a été déplacée pour
des raisons de covid mais c'est bien la
Chine qu'il a préside et qui a déjà dit
qu'il était hors de question qu'elle
s'engage elle à la moindre protection de
ses eaux maritimes parce qu'elle n'en
n'avait pas 30% à protéger compte tenu
de ses besoins
je vous donne ce point et le reste
évidemment à l'avenant je pense que là
dessus il faut vraiment que jusqu'au
début de cette Cope en décembre on
continue de maintenir une pression et
qu'on essaie d'arracher tout ce qu'il
faut je vais pas vous parler de la
sixième extinction mais juste vous
rappeler que même dans notre pays 18%
des 14000 espèces avec lesquelles nous
vivons sont en situation de menace j'en
arrive aux ânes
je veux remercier le Sénat sans ironie
parce que la toute première question
gouvernement qui m'a été posée était sur
le sujet et j'ai pu mesurer à quel point
le relais fin n'en vous disposez sur les
territoires
précédaient les interpellations des
associations des lieux de proximité que
j'ai pu rencontrer partout
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
choses un dès le début du mois d'août
j'ai demandé au préfet de lever les
stylos et d'arrêter d'appliquer par
anticipation ce qui était dans les
décrets du 29 avril dont j'avais
souligné la nécessité de la réécriture
des milieux du mois de juillet
comme prévu les conférences de Scott
dont nous ne pouvions pas déplacer la
date qui était calée au 22 octobre
puisqu'elle avait été calé de manière
législative et donc n'avions pas
l'espace législatif pour bouger cette
date ont permis de constater qu'il n'y
avait nulle part le moindre raccord ou
le moindre consensus et donc que dans
ces conditions c'était vers les régions
dans le cadre des stradettes que les
obligations de définir la
territorialisation du zan ne se posait
dans cette intervalle la consultation a
commencé ici au Sénat notamment avec les
quatre commissions qui se sont réunies
dans le groupe de travail j'ai déjà vu
j'avais vu fin août à sa demande des
membres de la commission du
développement économique et de la
Commission de développement durable et
j'ai eu un temps d'échange avec cette
commission spéciale j'ai vu les députés
j'ai reçu les principales associations
des Luc locaux pour leur partager avec
tous et le fait qu'il y avait une
ambition que nous remettions pas en
cause sur le 0 artificialisation nette
mais que manifestement en termes de
méthodes il y avait des choses à revoir
ce qui est acté c'est le
décrenomenclature j'attends pour le mois
de novembre le retour des agences
d'urbanisme qui ont travaillé avec des
villes pour reprendre toutes les
caractéristiques du décret nomenclature
gardez ce qui est intelligent ce qui ne
l'est pas et faire en sorte évidemment
tout ça soit raccord en particulier avec
ce qui pourrait se décider dans le cadre
de la loi sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables
deuxième point il y a un consensus qui
se fait jour sur la nécessité d'avoir un
comté à part national pour les projets
d'importance nationale on ne peut pas
laisser à la région des hautes-français
Nord-Europe ou les LGV pour la région
Occitanie ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
considérer qu'il y a pas
d'artificialisation quand c'est un grand
projet mais ça veut dire qu'on ne peut
pas ajouter
au retard parfois lié à des grandes
opérations des enclavagements ou à des
opérations qui sont majeures pour nous
permettre de décarboner une partie de
nos transports un poids en termes de
surface qui viendrait menacer les
objectifs que nous poursuivons
troisièmement il faut qu'on corrige un
certain nombre de choses et je pense en
particulier à l'application du solde dès
maintenant et pas seulement à partir de
l'horizon de 2031 et puis on a quelques
questions périphériques en particulier
parce que les régions disent qu'elles
veulent bien discuter mais que le temps
dont elle dispose va être court
puisqu'on a pas encore stabilisé les
règles et que les 15 ou 16 mois dont on
parle entre le mois d'octobre le 22
octobre et le 22 février même si la
période peut être intelligente et ce que
vraiment du coup la date de départ
correspond au 22 octobre puisque les
textes ne sont désormais plus stabilisés
j'ajoute pour aller très très vite parce
que ça m'emmènerait beaucoup trop loin
qu'il y a encore un certain nombre de
sujets
deux en particulier le premier c'est
comment on fait dans les plus petites
communes de ce pays pour pas que on
fasse le zéro artificialisation net sur
leur dos et qui est une répartition de
l'effort qui se fasse de manière juste
et il y a un sujet je suis totalement
opposé à dire qu'il y a des communes
dans lesquelles on n'applique pas le zan
mais je ne peux pas être insensible à
l'argument qui consiste à laisser penser
que que ce sont les intercommunalités et
les régions qui décident on peut avoir
des effets de bord et qu'une forme de
garantie ou de réserves pourraient
permettre de préserver à la fois
l'ambition l'objectif et de trouver des
voies aménagement pour être capable
d'avancer et puis il y a la question du
financement et de l'accompagnement des
collectivités et je dois revoir le
rapporteur de la mission spéciale
Jean-Baptiste blanc sur la question des
évolutions de fiscalité nous
réfléchissons trop sur comment on aide
les mers à rendre moins cher la
dépollution des friches et pas assez
comment est-ce qu'on se débrouille pour
rendre plus cher l'artificialisation des
terres si on est contre l'étalement
urbain il est pas exclu de se poser
aussi la question d'une forme de
fiscalité qui rend chérisse le coup de
cet artificialisation et qui puisse
fournir des moyens en collectivité pour
de l'autre côté équilibrer des
opérations de renaturation des
pollutions
je vais laisser
Dominique Faure répondre aux
interrogations du président Longeot sur
les Ederer ses revenus plusieurs fois
oui alors
en fait comme vous le savez tous elles
ont été
prorogées
jusqu'au 31 12 2023 et donc des
monarrivés au gouvernement
Christophe Béchu m'a mandaté pour
travailler avec plusieurs documents dont
le rapport
des sénateurs et sénatrices Frédéric
Espagnac et Bernard d'escroc donc dès
juillet je faisais une première réunion
de travail nous en avons fait plusieurs
et nous avons nous les avons reçus avec
Monsieur philizo que beaucoup d'entre
vous connaissent qui ont porté qui a
porté les ZRR sur les fonds bâtissements
en
1995 et qui a accepté une mission que je
lui ai confiée pour nous accompagner
avec le DGCL qui est quand même la
direction dans laquelle les simulations
sont faites pour nous éclairer sur ce
que pourrait être les et derrière à
partir de janvier 24 donc nous sommes au
début d'un travail que nous conduisons
avec Monsieur filizeau et avec la DGCL
avec les parlementaires c'est pour ça
que je vous disais en introduction que
d'ici 15 jours nous verrions une
délégation de parlementaire pour ceux
qui étaient présents j'ai interpellé
monsieur le Président du Sénat parce que
je me suis
demandé pour quelle raison nous
n'aurions pas un groupe ruralité qui
pourrait pendant quelques mois nous
accompagner plutôt que de voir les
différentes commissions et les
différents groupes politiques ça ne me
pose aucun problème je verrai autant de
fois que vous le souhaitez les groupes
politiques ainsi que les commissions
pour travailler avec vous il m'a
lui-même indiqué que ce rapport existait
qu'il fallait travailler avec les
sénateurs je viens de citer ce que je
fais mais je vous invite à prendre
contact encore une fois avec mon cabinet
si vous souhaitez être associé
étroitement à nos travaux
alors
l'eau et l'air
qui valent aussi bien dans la ruralité
que dans les villes et sur lesquelles
j'ai eu deux questions du sénateur
Chevrollier
d'abord sur l'eau à ce stade je
n'envisage pas une loi parce que je
considère qu'il y a des quantités de
marge d'amélioration dans ce dont nous
disposons et le temps qu'on mettrait à
faire une loi nous détournerait de
beaucoup de mesures que nous devons
d'ores et déjà entreprendre et pour
lequel il y a ou des solutions sur
étagères ou des moyens de réfléchir et
pour lequel il y a des problèmes de
budget ou de réglementation mais pas
législatif le cadre c'est quoi c'est
celui des assises de l'eau et du varen
les assises Zelda de 2019 le varen est
date de 2021 et que en un an et demi on
n'est pas réussi encore à diminuer le
niveau des prélèvements agricoles alors
qu'il y a des feuilles de route filière
par filière qui sont des en train d'être
organisés c'est pas lié à un défaut de
diligence des agriculteurs ou de
législateur c'est juste lié au fait que
on fixe une ambition et ensuite il faut
un minimum de temps pour que les choses
se fassent je redis ce que j'ai dit dans
l'hémicycle le fait d'avoir une
agriculture qui soit capable de
consommer moins d'eau c'est vital
ça l'est pour la ressource mais ça l'est
pour qu'on puisse se nourrir et ça l'est
pour que on se retrouve pas dans un
dispositif où on durcissant les règles
chez nous on augmente des importations
qui seraient et mauvaises pour le climat
avec des tonnes de CO2 qui seraient
importantes voire mauvaise pour la santé
parce qu'il y a peu de pays qui sont
aussi regardant que nous sur les
conditions de production de notre
agriculture
ça veut pas dire qu'on a pas de marge de
progression je pourrais évidemment y
venir mais je veux donner cet indication
qu'est-ce qu'on a lancé enfin septembre
à Marseille le 29 dans un configuration
dans une configuration inédite avec le
ministère de la Santé de l'agriculture
nous avons réuni le Conseil national de
l'eau
tous les bassins
préfèrent et élus et des quantités
d'acteurs en leur disant voilà
exactement le retour d'expérience qu'on
a sur cette sécheresse voilà les pistes
dans lesquelles on se travaille vous
nous rendez pour la fin de l'année la
manière dont on arrive à une partie de
ces objectifs
la sécheresse de cet été c'est dix mois
sur 12 de déficit plusieurs métriques
avec un mois de juillet qui a battu tous
les records 88%
d'absence de pluie par rapport au mois
de juillet normal
les leçons c'est d'abord un décret qui
permet désormais de monitorer de prendre
des décisions sur les etiages pendant
l'hiver nous avons encore aujourd'hui
une situation de sécheresse dans près de
50 départements de ce pays je corrige
nous avons encore dans 50 départements
des arrêtés de restriction qui sont en
vigueur à l'instant où on se parle
indépendamment du fait qu'on a dans la
quasi-totalité pas retrouvé les niveaux
d'eau normaux
et avec des écarts
assez préoccupants ça l'est sur le
niveau de la Loire mais aujourd'hui on a
vraiment en Bretagne une situation qui
est particulièrement complexe
face à ça comment on arrête de gaspiller
où on évite de perdre de la ressource
dans mon viseur il y a d'abord les 20%
en moyenne de perte de nos réseaux d'eau
potable il faut pas raconter d'histoires
0 ça n'existe pas mais la performance
des réseaux varie de 5 à 70%
donc on a des marges et je vous précise
que de l'eau qui a été potabilisée ça
veut dire qu'en plus on a consommé de
l'énergie pour être capable d'y parvenir
là-dessus je suis pas certain que les
solutions plairont à tout le monde
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que dans un
certain nombre de cas la quasi-totalité
des communes qui ont été privées d'eau
potable étaient des communes qui gérait
l'eau toute seule sans interconnexion
on s'est rendu compte que celle qui sont
les plus menacées après pour lesquels il
leur aurait fallu déployer des
bouteilles d'eau en plastique à grande
échelle était souvent aussi dans ce type
de situation et que c'est le manque
d'interconnexion et donc parfois le
manque d'investissement
qui explique l'état du réseau et donc
quand on se targue de dire j'ai l'eau la
moins chère de France il va aussi
falloir si on se qu'on apprenne à se
poser la question de savoir si on a
l'eau la plus disponible parce que l'eau
la moins chère si elle est disponible
que 9 mois sur 12 ça change un peu la
donne et si ensuite c'est au syndicat ou
à la commune de payer l'eau potable pour
l'ensemble des habitants ça aura des
conséquences qu'il faudra qu'on intègre
on a un énorme sujet sur la
réutilisation des eaux
0,8% de nos eaux usées retraités sont
réutilisés c'est dix fois moins qu'en
Italie 20 fois moins qu'en Espagne 100
fois moins qu'en Israël
on a donc des marges sans aller jusque
sur le model israélien pour au moins
être capable de faire comme les Italiens
pour arroser des massifs dans nos villes
utiliser de l'eau potable c'est quand
même un usage qui peut questionner il y
a des quantités de cas dans lequel on
doit être capable de bouger là-dessus
puisque la ressource elle existe et puis
c'est amplifié ces feuilles
métiers par métier qui permettent de
diminuer les consommations d'eau mais
c'est le faire avec les professions
concernées pour pas que ce soit au
détriment de tout ça donc voilà les
grands chantiers j'entre pas plus dans
le détail je réponds sur l'absence de
loi sur l'air
1 14 octobre de cette année
puisque vous m'avez cité le 17 le 17 la
France est condamnée le 14 on a le
rapport annuel sur la qualité de l'air
qui permet de mesurer qu'encore une fois
la qualité de l'air dans le pays c'est
améliorée l'arrêt du Conseil d'étape
pointe le fait que il n'augmente pas le
niveau des astreintes parce qu'il
constate l'amélioration de la situation
de la qualité de l'air en 2017 on a très
agglos en dépassement
ce chiffre il tombe à 8 en 2020 à 5 en
2021 et à trois et demi en 2022
je parle des arrêts du Conseil d'État
mettre en place les zones
affaiblissement ça marche les premiers
retours que nous avons à l'intérieur du
périmètre de l'A86 ces 50 000 habitants
qui sont sortis du seuil de dépassement
depuis la mise en place de la ZF
l'enjeu c'est comment la met en place
sans remettre des octroies ou des
barrières de péage à l'entrée des villes
qui donnent le sentiment que les gueux
qui roulent au diesel ils ont le droit
de rester à l'extérieur et qui sont pas
les bienvenus dans les centres villes
qui sont peuplés par les bobos à vélo
je vous le fais comme ça parce que le
risque demain si c'est la lecture qui en
est faite c'est à nouveau de dresser les
Français les uns contre les autres sur
un sujet qui devrait tous nous
rassembler c'est d'éviter c'est d'éviter
les morts de la pollution atmosphérique
vous m'avez posé plein de questions
ah non c'est Monsieur gilet qui est
rentré mais donc je vais tout de suite
faire le lien bon l'enjeu c'est quoi
d'abord c'est pas altérer la mobilité
des gens et donc c'est d'avoir des
solutions de remplacement ça suppose des
investissements sur les transports en
commun
ça suppose d'avoir des stratégies dans
les centres villes d'alternatives à la
voiture individuelle
le plan vélo est un moyen d'aller
accompagner les territoires mais pas
pour tout le monde même si le vélo
assistance électrique permet d'augmenter
de façon assez considérable la distance
moyenne qu'on peut faire par rapport au
vélo classique et les 250 millions qui
sont mis à une dernière c'est à dire le
doublement du rythme moyen annuel du
plan numéro 1 dit quelque chose et de
l'ambition et du succès 40%
d'augmentation de la pratique cyclable
depuis le covid 39 pour être précis pour
ceux qui voudraient vérifier les
chiffres
dans tout ça la stratégie des
carbonation des véhicules elle repose
sur le changement de motorisation
mais il faut qu'on ajoute deux trucs à
court terme
si on va trop vite sur l'électrification
à la minute où on se parle ça veut dire
qu'on subventionne l'industrie chinoise
qui fabrique des véhicules moins chers
dans des usines qui sont alimentées au
charbon
à court terme je pousse pour un plan
massif de covoiturage pas un chèque
quand vous inscrivez sur la plateforme
je propose qu'on regarde de près ce que
font les territoires qui connaissent des
doublement tous les mois du nombre de
covoitureurs j'en connais deux Rouen et
Angers
qu'est-ce qui s'est fait dans ces deux
territoires nous réunirons les
covoitureurs
on donne de l'argent le nombre de
trajets éviter et les tonnes de CO2 sont
monitorables
que l'état de main se pose la question
de pouvoir appuyer des dispositifs pour
amorcer ça aurait du bon j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que c'est le seul
moyen à très très court terme
sans acquisition de véhicules sans
déploiement de bornes de tout de suite
lutter contre l'auto-solisme on est
passé
en 40 ans de 2,3 personnes en moyenne
par véhicule à 1,6 et ça n'est pas que
sous l'effet de la dénatalité
plus de 90% des trajets pour aller au
travail se font tout seul
et on peut immédiatement en favorisant
le covoiturage diminuer les coûts et
faire en sorte de diminuer les émissions
carbone du transport en n'étant pas
amené à penser à un réseau qui doit être
notre ambition mais qui est pas
disponible demain matin deuxième levier
le rétrofit
comment on pousse des gens à changer le
moteur de leur véhicule sans
nécessairement changer la totalité du
véhicule et là j'arrive à la question de
Monsieur G une voiture avant de parler
de gabarit ces deux tonnes de pétrole
pour la produire donc la réflexion sur
l'obsolescence en cycle de vie et sur le
fait qu'il n'y a pas que les émissions
une fois qu'on l'a construite mais qui a
le fait de la construire milite pour
qu'on ne gêne pas qu'on ne jette pas des
voitures qui sont pas assez vieilles et
qui ont déjà eu un coup carbone
particulièrement élevé et donc il faut
qu'on soit capable de gérer les deux la
question du poids est déterminante pour
deux raisons d'abord parce qu'elle
produit
elle aussi une pollution atmosphérique
il y a ce qu'on appelle l'abrasion c'est
le sujet des freins c'est le sujet du
poids et ça ça pourrait être pris en
charge dans le cadre de la norme Euro 7
j'entre pas là dedans nous militons
seulement pour qu'elle ne soit pas
réservée aux véhicules thermiques qui
n'y ait pas de nouvelles mesures
concernant les moteurs parce que toute
la R&D doit aller sur l'électrique et
pas envoyer un contre signal à
l'industrie les sans penser qu'on
pourrait continuer à préparer des
moteurs thermiques pour l'après 2035
l'avantage du freinage ou de ce genre de
choses c'est que ça vaut pour le
thermique et pour l'électrique
il est trop tôt pour faire un retour du
malus puisque la décision date du 1er
janvier de cette année je peux vous
donner des chiffres au 31 août un peu
plus de 300 millions d'euros qui sont
entrés dans les caisses mais on ne sait
pas ce qui est l'aggravation du malus
écologique à la minute où on se parle et
la fameuse taxe pour les véhicules de
plus de 1 tonnes 8 qui a été introduite
suite aux remarques notamment
de la convention de la loi climat
résilience donc je pourrai pas être plus
précis sur le prêt à taux zéro il
commence
il commence au premier janvier 2023 donc
quand vous appelez de vos vœux des
modifications je pense sincèrement que
si on avait une année pour repérer qui
s'en sert qui ne s'en sert pas et ce qui
se passe ce serait pas choquant sur sa
mise en œuvre mon sujet c'est la
garantie
un rapport
législatif pointe l'intérêt qu'il y
aurait avoir une garantie de l'État sur
ce dispositif pour éviter qu'on ait des
refus de prêt à taux zéro de la part des
banques notamment pour des ménages qui
auraient déjà atteint les 30% de
capacité d'emprunt et dans un contexte
où l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
fait qu'il y aura sans doute une
attention de la part des organismes
bancaires accrus au fait de prêter de
l'argent à temps 0 s'ils n'ont pas la
certitude de récupérer leur capital un
dispositif de couverture à hauteur de
50% pour le microcrédit déjà dans ce
cadre-là a été mis en oeuvre le prêt à
taux zéro il est beaucoup plus ambitieux
parce qu'il s'applique aussi à du
leasing de longue durée
et pas seulement de l'acquisition et il
a un avantage c'est qu'il est
mobilisable pour de l'occasion ce qui me
permet de reboucler la boucle par
rapport au sujet on doit pas seulement
avoir l'obsession de se demander comment
les gens achètent des voitures neuves
mais comment on les aide à acquérir des
véhicules d'occasion parce que la somme
des primes existante pour le coup elle
diminue singulièrement le reste à payer
un ménage qui trouverait un véhicule
d'occasion à 10000 euros le problème
c'est qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui des
masses disponibles compte tenues de la
jeunesse du parc il aurait un reste à
payer de 3000 euros s'il pouvait
bénéficier de la surprise et des feux de
1000 euros des 1000 euros qui sont liés
à la prime
des 7000 euros annoncés par le Président
de la République dans le cadre
du bonus écologique et de la partie sur
la prime à la conversion
mais une fois qu'on a dit tout ça
le sujet ça va effectivement être et
donc sur le PTZ y compris sur la
domiciliation à proximité c'était trop
imprécie pour permettre ensuite de
savoir qui on retenait et donc la
domiciliation à proximité est devenue à
l'intérieur de n'importe quel des
communes ou à condition de travailler à
l'intérieur du secteur j'attire votre
attention si vous retouchez à ces
dispositifs de prime il me semble que la
durée de deux ans qui est l'obligation
de conservation du véhicule quand elle a
il a bénéficié de plusieurs milliers
voire de plus de 10000 euros de prime me
semble un peu courtes si on réfléchit en
cycle de vie et que d'imposer une durée
de conservation plus longue serait de
meilleure politique
j'ajoute quatre types personnelles je
considère que l'évolution du barème de
remboursement fiscal des entreprises
permettrait d'intégrer la dimension de
poids que vous évoquez je ne comprends
pas pourquoi on rembourse les kilomètres
sur la base des chevaux fiscaux si on
veut inciter les gens à la sobriété on
aurait un tarif unique qui permettrait
d'inciter les gens et être responsable
je pense que ce serait un levier qui
enverra un petit signal et qui
accessoirement ne coûte pas d'argent à
l'état tout dépend si vous l'alignez sur
le plus haut sur le plus bas mais je
fais confiance à la sagesse sénatoriale
pour que ce soit au pire sur la médiane
sur les lectures des plaques
d'immatriculation on le saura bientôt
nous lançons le marché de ces radars
l'État va déployer 0 radar 0
nous devons conduire la procédure le
processus d'homologation pour qu'ensuite
les collectivités qui le souhaitent puis
choisir les moyens qui leur permettront
de faire respecter les zones à faibles
mission je dis des choses telles
qu'elles sont à la minute où on se parle
un maire peut déjà
conduire des opérations de vérification
dès lors que vous avez une ZFE qui a des
véhicules qui sont stationnement rien
n'empêche les ASVP ou les agents de
police municipales d'appliquer le
dispositif s'ils le souhaitent
qu'on explique à l'état que c'est de sa
faute parce qu'il y a pas les radars
sachant que par potentiellement dans le
même temps
certains alertes aussi sur les risques
d'explosion sociale il faut il faut
choisir
on donne les moyens aux maires de
pouvoir ensuite mettre en place des
politiques à l'échelle de leur
territoire il décide de l'amplitude il
décide des exclusions il décide du
rythme dans lequel les choses se font
ils décident des procédures
d'accompagnement et il y a une pluralité
de façon de faire à Lyon c'est 7 jours
sur 7 24 heures sur 24 à Paris c'est pas
le soir et les week-ends
tous les six mois de voir tout le monde
et de recueillir les bonnes pratiques la
lecture à plaque d'immatriculation
permettra d'enregistrer dans la base de
données les véhicules qu'on exclut de la
verbalisation si on le souhaite
en ce qui concerne l'aménagement
numérique madame la ministre
alors
donc vous avez rappelé monsieur le
sénateur c'était vous
le problème que nous rencontrons sur la
spéculation des infrastructures au
téléphone immobilier donc rappeler que
autant dans nos zones blanches et en
ruralité nos pylônes sont mutualisés
autant chaque opérateur mais
son propre équipement de
télécommunications en haut les durées
d'amortissement de ces équipements de
télécommunications en haut des pylônes
sont plus longs que la durée
d'amortissement des pylônes qui ne sont
que de 12 ans donc à l'issue de ces 12
ans celui qui arrive à être propriétaire
du pylône et bien peut faire payer le
loyer qu'il veut à ceux qui voudraient
s'installer en haut oui monsieur le
sénateur c'est remonté jusqu'à nous
a-t-on la solution aujourd'hui non
monsieur le sénateur par contre nous y
travaillons avec notre collègue
Jean-Noël Barrault dès aujourd'hui
donc en résumé ce que ce que je peux
vous dire de très officiel et qui
corroborent ce que vous dites c'est que
le dispositif prévu par la loi emprunte
environnementale numérique pour les
nouvelles constructions est estimée trop
fragile s'agissant des infrastructures
existantes qui représentent pourtant la
quasi-totalité des difficultés
rencontrées donc
je vous propose
on va dire dans un dans un délai de deux
mois de vous dire comment nous
entrevoyons de sortir de cette impasse
ou de cette possible spéculation sur les
infrastructures de téléphonie mobile sur
le guichet de cohésion numérique des
territoires donc vous nous rappeler à
quel point il a été précieux ça a été la
mise en place et vous l'avez dit d'une
aide majorée à 300 euros pour une offre
permettant des débits supérieurs ou
égaux à 30 mégabits et puis jusqu'à 600
euros pour des loyers les plus modestes
sous conditions de ressources alors oui
effectivement vous demande de Riez
l'élargissement de ce guichet de
cohésion des territoires à toutes les
difficultés rencontrées sur tous le
territoire de zone blanche pour
l'instant ce n'est pas ce que nous
étudions nous étudions alors je voudrais
vous donner quand même quelques chiffres
qui sont extrêmement parlants et qui
peut-être peuvent mettre du baume au
coeur à tous ceux qui attendent une
meilleure couverture donc on est bien
sûr deux sujets la téléphonie mobile
avec de la 4G essentiellement dans les
zones blanches mais aussi parfois de la
5G et puis du très haut débit fixe avec
de la fibre optique et donc pour ce qui
est de la couverture mobile pas moins de
971 sites ont été notifiés aux
opérateurs et dont seulement 322 sites
ont été mis en service donc nous sommes
en attente de déploiement de 60 sites
d'accord donc on est assez content de
l'efficacité de ce New Deal mobile
cependant la couverture à ce jour
[Musique]
je voulais vous donner le pourcentage
mais je ne l'ai pas je ne l'ai pas ici
pour ce qui est de la téléphonie mobile
mais enfin on a voisine les 90% de
couverture avec ses relais et s'épilogne
qui sont engagés mais qui ne sont pas
encore déployés allez-y
[Musique]
dans les territoires ruraux mais on
n'est pas à 100% aujourd'hui ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que la
technologie satellitaire pour ceux qui
ne la connaissent pas je vous invite à
l'explorer elle va permettre de
compléter y compris en montagne dans des
crevasses par exemple dans lesquels des
gens pourraient tomber et pour des
sujets de prévention de sécurité elle va
permettre de compléter ce que la 4G ou
bien le haut débit fixe ne pourra pas
accomplir en termes de couverture
nationale
je veux dire au sénateur marchand ce qui
concerne la recherche
1 et que le dispositif d'amortisseur
d'électricité va valoir pour toutes les
administrations de que le 27 octobre
près de 300 millions d'euros
complémentaires spécifiques pour les
universités les recherches ont été
décidées et pour l'Institut polaire
à la minute où nous parlons je pense que
si les taillot a annoncé une bonne
nouvelle à la commission Culture par
laquelle l'été auditionné pour l'assurer
que les crédits réclamaient notamment
dans le cadre d'une tribune seront bien
au rendez-vous
je veux dire au sénateur Martin
concernant les ICPE
et en fait que je ne sais pas bien
pourquoi il me questionne parce que il
connaît le dossier par coeur et donc il
a fait état finalement des réponses que
mon administration lui a faite et qui
m'ont également été transmises pour lui
répondre et moi je vais me livrer à
l'exercice
pourquoi est-ce que c'est parfois un peu
complexe parce qu'il faut bien mesurer
qu'il y a 1089
et TP de mon ministère qui sont mis à
disposition des Dréal mais il y en a un
certain nombre qui le sont par le
ministère de l'Agriculture et donc sur
les consolidations de chiffres le fait
d'avoir cette interministériel explique
pourquoi il peut y avoir un léger
flottement quand on demande à combien
d'unités exactes nous sommes en revanche
pour moi pour ce qui me concerne c'est
1089 et ce chiffre augmente de 20
l'année prochaine il a augmenté de 37
années parce que l'ambition
d'augmentation des contrôles elle est
réelle les 18 000 de 18 de 2018
sont devenus 22 000 en 2021
nous ne ferons pas vous avez raison de
le dire les 27000 cette année en
particulier parce qu'il y a des postes
pour lesquels nous sommes encore en face
de recrutement mais c'est l'ambition et
l'objectif que j'ai rappelé à mon
ministère pour 2023 donc on est bien sur
une progression tous les ans parce qu'il
y a une progression des effectifs on
n'est pas encore à l'ambition que nous
sommes nous-mêmes fixés sur le CNDP sur
la scène des pelles la Commission
nationale du débat public
ces moyens sont au taux d'augmentation
et ils sont en augmentation d'un demi
million d'euros précisément pour tenir
compte des missions importantes qui sont
les siennes et des échanges que j'ai pu
avoir avec la présidente Jouano je vais
pas aller plus loin puisque ensuite il
me pas appartient pas de me prononcer
sur la qualité du travail que fait la
Commission nationale du débat public
sur la SN augmentation de postes là
aussi pour l'année qui arrive et la
pente restera la même les 6 qui
augmentent pour 2023 correspondent à la
demande de la SN
et je vous confirme qu'on est bien sur
un renforcement plus réel compte tenu
des ambitions qui existent par ailleurs
le sénateur Louis Jean de Nicolaï a posé
la question de la NCT après nous avoir
dit qu'il limiterait ces questions sur
la partie cohésion des territoires après
avoir épuisé Caroline caillot dans le
même exercice
je vais demander à Dominique fort de lui
répondre d'un mot mais Caroline caillou
a été particulièrement soumise à la
question sur la NCT dans sa qualité
d'anciennes présidente si vous souhaitez
qu'on vous refasse une partie de tout ça
on peut le refaire sur la feuille de
route plus réelle et sur la partie
Action cœur de ville et petite ville de
demain
oui juste trois mots pour rappeler que
le contrat
d'objectif est de performance de la NCT
qu'il y ait la DGCL à la NCT portait sur
les années 2021 2023 avec trois
objectifs moi qui arrive dans ce
gouvernement je peux vous dire que je
trouve que les indicateurs sont là les
objectifs sont là après les résultats
sont excellents il faut aussi en mesurer
l'efficacité par des rencontres avec les
élus locaux qu'on bénéficier des aides
mais rappelez que les trois objectifs
étaient clairs donc c'est des programmes
nationaux on les connaît bien ces
petites villes de demain c'est c'est le
déploiement du numérique c'est tous ces
programmes que la NCT a porté au service
des collectivités c'est de l'ingénierie
sur mesure deuxième objectif franchement
moi je n'ai pas fait un seul déplacement
on ne met pas dit du bien de ces
programmes d'accompagnement en
ingénierie et puis là aussi c'était moi
je trouve extrêmement innovant de
l'avoir anticipé quand la NCT a été
créée des problématiques d'animation des
acteurs pour ceux qui ont embarqué des
programmes comme le programme petite
ville de demain 2600
petite non 1600 petites villes de demain
et bien le réseau qui a été créé par les
chefs de projets qui sont allés sur ces
territoires pendant un an deux ans est
incroyablement dynamique a fait de la
fertilisation croisée était d'une
efficacité incroyable ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les les loyers les
les camemberts d'évaluation d'efficacité
donc des objectifs ont été mis en place
en termes d'évaluation des politiques
publiques il y a vraiment rien à dire en
2021 on a on a à peine atteint les
objectifs en 2022 on les dépasse par
rapport aux critères qui étaient mis en
place par rapport aux trois objectifs
que je viens de vous donner sur ceux qui
s'inquiètent sur les deux programmes
phares que sont actions coeur de ville
et petite ville de demain et bien 2023
on a les budgets pour le programme
Action cœur de ville et pour PVD on l'a
jusqu'en 2026 pour ceux qui s'inquiètent
sur le fait que certains mères auraient
porté des aurait réalisé de la réflexion
de l'ingénierie et aurait des projets
près et se dirait où vais-je trouver
l'argent pour maintenant mettre en œuvre
on a créé des attentes avec de
l'ingénierie et il nous faut maintenant
financer je vous rappeler quand même que
la décide pour ceux qui avaient pas les
ordres grandeurs et je pense que vous
l'avez tous en tête c'est quand même
770 millions d'euros que on est à 1
milliard deux pour la DETR qui vient
spécifiquement dans les environnements
ruraux et qu'on est à 2 milliards de
fonds verts parce que vous avez demandé
on est à 2 milliards de fond vert en
investissement donc le problème du
financement des infrastructures dont les
mers en ruralité auraient besoin à
l'issue d'un programme d'ingénierie de
réflexion pour leur rénovation de centre
ville il y a pas de problème
d'investissement effectivement il faudra
financer en auto-financement autour de
20% et effectivement c'est là que les
mers peuvent dire je n'ai pas 20% avec
les difficultés que je rencontre
actuellement j'ai des problèmes mais
voilà on peut rassurer nos mères sur le
fait que en investissement nous avons
les montants qui vont bien pour mettre
en oeuvre les travaux qu'ils ont qui ont
abouti à l'issue des phases d'ingénierie
toujours de manière très rapide et très
succincte je réponds à la sénatrice
Evelyne Perrot
et je commence par sa deuxième question
la première c'était sur les avions
propres la seconde c'était sur les jet
privé
sur les jets privés la décision le texte
qui vous est soumis à ligne le taux de
TICPE du kérosène sur l'aviation
d'affaires sur celui de l'aviation de
loisirs ou du transport routier c'est à
dire qu'il augmente de
70%. voilà la réponse précise à la
mesure qui est proposée
sur les avions propres avec les
guillemets qui vont bien puisque là
aussi il faut produire les véhicules
mais posons le principe demain des
déplacements en avion des carbonés on
nous annonce les premiers avions
électriques pour 2025
avec un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
travaillent sur le sujet je suis
incapable de vous dire si la date de
2025 est crédible je vous dis ce qu'on
me dit et en particulier
ce y compris ce que la presse a pu
relater avec une start-up notamment
toulousaine sur le sujet le patron
d'Airbus a laissé entendre que nous
parviendrions à un avion à hydrogène
aux mi-temps des années 2030 ce qui
n'est pas le consensus de tous les
avionneurs d'autres disant
que ça leur semble très ambitieux et
trop proche je ne sais pas répondre plus
loin à ces questions ce que je sais
c'est que l'OACI
qui est l'Organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale qui se réunit à
Montréal à adopter il y a quelques jours
une feuille de route pour aller vers la
décarbonation de l'aviation ce qui est
une nouveauté parce que ce n'était pas
parmi les secteurs qui poussaient le
plus je pense qu'il y a aussi une prise
de conscience notamment de la part de
leur client que indépendamment des
prises de position des uns et des autres
il y a une attente à faire en sorte de
décarboner tous les modes de transport
ça a été rappelé les transports c'est
30% des émissions même si les deux tiers
de ses émissions ce sont les voitures
les émissions les plus importantes au
kilomètre parcourues elles se font
évidemment avec l'avion
j'ai eu ensuite
des questions de la part du sénateur
Tabaro sur le ferroviaire d'abord je ne
considère pas que 150 millions d'euros
correspondent à un grand soir
ferroviaire et on n'a jamais présenté
les choses de cette manière je vous
rassure
le rendez-vous il est bientôt il est
effectivement quand on aura pas
seulement le rapport du coi mais la
planification écologique au sens large
que va devenir l'amendement des 3
milliards d'euros voté lundi et ça prend
évidemment tout son sens depuis une
vingtaine de minutes puisque c'était une
vingtaine de minutes qu'Elizabeth borne
a officiellement activer le 49-3 en fait
ces 3 milliards n'ont pas été votés ou
plutôt ils l'ont été
mais l'assemblée a constaté juste au
moment du vote que le gage avait déjà
servi pour financer la progression des
crédits sur la rénovation donc c'est un
amendement qui a reçu une majorité mais
qui n'a pas techniquement rempli les
conditions pour être pour être intégrées
indépendamment du 49-3 à la première
mouture puisque à l'instant du vote il a
été constaté qu'il n'y avait plus de
gage qui n'avait plus de crédit et donc
qui ne s'appliquait pas
le fond du sujet c'est bien comment on
ventile ces crédits nouveaux d'un point
de vue ferroviaire
et là
monsieur le sénateur c'est l'enjeu de la
planification écologique c'est de
chiffrer pas seulement combien ça nous
coûte en euros mais combien ça nous fait
éviter en carbone
c'est la question de l'efficacité
climatique des décisions que nous
prenons les besoins d'investissement
dans le ferroviaire sont gigantesques
mais tous les investissements ne se
valent pas la régénération elle est
cruciale parce qu'elle permet d'éviter
qu'on arrête des lignes
mais sur les travaux nouveaux qu'on soit
capable de se poser la question du
nombre de véhicules qu'on évite donc du
nom de tonnes qu'on évite ce sera
crucial ça militera vraisemblablement
pour que les RER métropolitains ne
soient pas trop loin du haut du paquet
parce que c'est sans doute les endroits
où on peut avoir le plus de choix de
report modal mais ça suppose aussi que
sur les distances les plus longues et
sur un certain nombre de petites lignes
on intègre ce paramètre pour qu'il y ait
des alternatives à la voiture là où
aujourd'hui ça génère des distances qui
sont très longues et ce chiffrage
climatique et je l'ai demandé à mes
services en même temps que les
chiffrages budgétaires pour que
l'ambition qui soit présentée forcément
de manière plus réelle quand la Première
ministre présentera la feuille de route
de planification écologique elle soit à
la hauteur des enjeux et c'est pas 150
millions et ça n'est pas non plus 3
milliards
enfin vous m'avez interrogé très vite
sur VNF
de mémoire VNF vous avez raison les
effectifs baisse l'année prochaine il
baisse moins que ce qui était anticipé
dans le plan uranuel pour les raisons
que vous avez indiquées on a remis des
effectifs par rapport à ce qui était la
trajectoire théorique les postes
supprimés correspondent uniquement aux
automatisations d'écluses qui
correspondent au programme pour l'année
qui arrive
je parle pour 2023 mais l'interrogation
sur la trajectoire plus réelle on est en
train de l'avoir pour les années qui
suivent on ne peut pas continuer à
demander des suppressions de poste à nos
opérateurs sans regarder les missions
qui sont rendus on veut développer le
frais de fluvial on veut et donc de la
même manière qu'on a déjà pris des
mesures pour Météo France et pour le FB
l'année prochaine nous regardons pour
VNF au-delà de l'année qui arrive où les
diminutions vous l'avez dit sont moins
élevés que les 80 qui figuraient
théoriquement dans le plan pluriannuel
de VNF
merci j'ai de la parole à Madame de ma
bien merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
secrétaire d'État
je souhaite vous interroger sur un sujet
relatif à l'accompagnement des personnes
éloignées du numérique à l'approche de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance par
notre assemblée j'aimerais vous
interroger plus particulièrement sur les
conseillers numériques françaises dont
le dispositif figure désormais dans la
mission fonction et transformation
publique du PLF 2023 je me réjouis
d'ailleurs de cette évolution qui répond
à une demande forte des élus locaux
j'aimerais cependant vous demander
certains éclairages selon la
documentation budgétaire 44 millions
d'euros sont ouverts en 2023 pour
financer la pérennisation de ce
dispositif à quoi cette enveloppe
correspond-t-elle exactement
s'agit-il de recruter davantage de
conseillers ou bien à effectif constant
de prolonger la période dans laquelle
l'État prend en charge leur rémunération
qui est actuellement limité à 24 mois et
jusqu'à quand l'État prévoit-il de
prendre en charge ce dispositif dont la
qui vient à peine d'être impulsé dans
les territoires avez-vous un bilan sur
ces deux années écoulées j'aurais aussi
Monsieur le Ministre une question de
notre ordre à vous poser qui porte sur
les enjeux économiques et financiers
surtout auxquels sont confrontées les
centres de soins de la faune sauvage
dont celui des Alpes-Maritimes
d'ailleurs qui m'a saisi ces centres
sont très importants pour la sauvegarde
de nombreuses espèces protégées et
menacées et bien que remplissant une
mission d'intérêt général pour la
biodiversité il ne bénéficie d'aucun
financement pérenne de l'État un audit a
bien été réalisé à l'été 2022 par
l'Inspection générale de l'environnement
afin d'étudier les modalités de création
d'une ligne budgétaire dans le projet de
loi de finances en cours d'examen
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
rassurer et nous faire connaître si une
ligne budgétaire a bien été retenue dans
le prolongement de l'annonce qui vient
d'être faite d'un fond vert doté de près
de 2 milliards d'euros et enfin
pour rebondir sur ces crédits nouveaux
d'un fond vert fléchés sur les
collectivités locales pouvez-vous nous
dire à quoi ils seront prioritairement
dédiés et selon quel modalités les
communes rurales qui rencontrent déjà de
grandes difficultés pour évaluer leurs
projets en l'absence bien souvent en
amont d'ingénierie pourront y prétendre
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Fabien Genet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la secrétaire d'État
je lis sur votre
sur votre cartouche qui est devant vous
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires moi ma
première question elle est sur la
cohésion des propositions qu'a le
gouvernement vis-à-vis de la de la
population en matière de décarbonation
je crois que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
sont en train de faire leur mutations
idéologique ou personnelle sur ces
sujets mais ce qu'on entend beaucoup sur
le territoire lorsque nous retrouvons
nos concitoyens c'est effectivement ce
paradoxe entre la promotion du véhicule
électrique que vous faites que fait
l'Union européenne avec cette ambition
majeure de 2035 et dans le même temps
l'appel a de la sobriété à ne pas
consommer l'électricité parce que le
gouvernement ne semble pas à même de
garantir l'accès à l'électricité à toute
la population au moins cet hiver
et donc j'ai une première interrogation
qui relait
celle de nos concitoyens est-ce que
finalement cet agenda avec une volonté
d'arrêter le moteur thermique en 2035
alors même que on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui garantir cette accès à
l'électricité est-ce que ces crédible et
comment on peut favoriser
l'acceptabilité l'adhésion de la
population à ce grand mouvement si on
n'est pas capable de d'avoir des
réponses de bon sens sur le sujet la
deuxième question que je voulais vous
poser monsieur le ministre madame la
secrétaire d'État dans un domaine un peu
différent quoique finalement une des
réponses à la problématique que je vais
exposer c'est de couvrir notre bocage
charolais de clôture électrique donc j'y
vois là quand même un certain lien je
vous parlais de la problématique de la
prédation du loup sur les troupeaux
domestiques est un vrai sujet pour nos
territoires ruraux
un sujet à la Confluence donc la
ruralité l'économie agricole mais
également la biodiversité et donc c'est
un vrai sujet
la présence du loup est avérée dans
notre département de Saône-et-Loire
depuis 2019 nous avons connu des
épisodes de prédation particulièrement
violent en 2020 dans le Charolais de mai
à novembre en 2021 dans le clunizoid
avril la juin et encore cette année en
début 2022 une dizaine d'attaques et une
centaine de victimes ont été attribués
au loup et chez nous en Saône-et-Loire
les systèmes d'élevage la conduite des
animaux en particulier en pâturage le
maillage bocagé de nos territoires
rendent nos exploitations
particulièrement vulnérables et
difficiles à protéger c'est pourquoi il
y a chez les éleveurs un véritable
désespoir une angoisse et une réelle
colère ceci demande donc une meilleure
protection des troupeaux est-ce que vous
pouvez vous engager à ce que l'État
octroie des tirs de défense simple et
renforcés dans de meilleures conditions
est-ce que vous êtes disposé à donner
plus de moyens au louvetier et à la
Brigade Mobile d'Intervention mais aussi
à améliorer le financement des
subventions pour la protection de ces
troupeaux est-ce que vous avez réfléchi
à une évolution du statut juridique des
chiens de protection de troupeau qui
posent un vrai sujet là aussi sur le
terrain une meilleure prise en compte
des pertes avec la valeur réelle et puis
il y a eu des interventions du Président
de la République en particulier sur le
sujet
sur le statut de la protection du loup
dans la convention de Berne et la
Directive Habitat est-ce que
effectivement la France est prête à
demander à ce que l'espace strictement
d'espèces pardon strictement protégé on
puisse passer le loup à un statut
d'espèces protégée et enfin pour
terminer sans vouloir électriser le
débat monsieur le ministre vous avez
effectivement évoqué le sujet de l'eau
et j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
ce que vous avez dit est-ce que votre
volonté très forte d'agir vite pourrait
se concrétiser par
une demande aux agences de l'eau de
pouvoir finalement consacrer des cette
année beaucoup plus de budget pour
subventionner les travaux d'amélioration
des performances des réseaux d'eau
puisque c'est un sujet qu'on évoque
depuis quelques années maintenant
merci la parole est à Angèle
la fin du véhicule thermique et
notamment parce que nous étions
dépendants fossiles et parce que nous
émettions des gaz à effet de serre avec
ces moteurs thermiques et nous allons
tomber dans une autre dépendance puisque
ce sont
que c'est une ressource limitée
également parce que tout est limité sur
terre donc comment anticipons ces choses
là ensuite sur le fond vert le fond vert
donc 2 milliards d'euros 200 millions
pour les départements donc 1800
à distribuer quel va être la répartition
et notamment parce que je vous parle
depuis un territoire rural donc qu'à ce
vous allez diviser par 100 c'est à dire
18 millions par département ou pas vous
allez tenir compte de la population ou
pas pour ces sujets là parce que sinon
dans mon département où il n'y a que
170000 habitants je pense que nous
n'aurons pas grand chose donc voilà
c'est pour en savoir un petit peu plus
ensuite sur
quelque chose de beaucoup plus général à
savoir que nous venons de dépasser cette
année deux limites planétaires
c'est-à-dire celles en janvier sur
l'introduction de nouvelles entités
chimiques dans l'environnement donc
seuil dépassé et également sur le cycle
de l'eau douce dépassé au mois de mai et
le cycle de l'eau douce c'est le fait
que l'ouverture les sols
dans les sols notamment les sols ne
retiennent plus l'eau bon en cause
l'agriculture intensive la monoculture
la déforestation et le changement
climatique donc comment envisagez-vous
ces deux grosses problématiques qui
concernent évidemment le monde entier
mais qui nous concerne aussi et je
voudrais porter un focus tout
particulier sur ma région qui est
l'Occitanie dans laquelle le changement
climatique est en train de s'installer
façon beaucoup plus forte qu'ailleurs je
siège au comité de bassin à
bourg-garonne nous avons perdu 20% de
plus vieux métrie
c'est déjà acté alors qu'on pense que
pour sur la France entière ça deviendra
que qu'en 2040 c'est-à-dire que nous en
2040 on aura beaucoup moins encore et
que nous subissons une sécheresse très
sévère et notamment les températures du
mois d'octobre qui viennent de ce qui
vient de se terminer ont été
particulièrement impactantes sur cette
région donc comment envisagez-vous de
décliner ces choses là et dernière
question sur les micropollions de l'eau
et notamment parce que on vient de une
récente étude montre que des vêtements
de sport continuons contiendraient du
bisphénol A or ces vêtements de sport
sont portés par les jeunes et l'on sait
que ce sont des perturbateurs
endocriniens et qui donc provoquent
agissent comme des hormones et provoque
des des problématiques comme des puberté
précoce donc impact très fortement la
genèse et on sait déjà c'est ces
choses-là sont en train de se mettre en
place dernière chose sur la pollution
plastique charmelcher donc Égypte
il y a en ce moment des pourparler pour
un traité contraignant sur cette
pollution plastique et comment
interviendrait vous en Egypte sachant
que le pays Égypte et un des principaux
contributeurs de la pollution plastique
en Méditerranée et que la Méditerranée
est connaît un une concentration de
micro plastique équivalente à celle des
Gires
très rapides déjà toutes ces questions
là parce que sinon il y a un moment où
les orateurs seront partis quand je
répondrai et vous la suite va devenir
compliqué en revanche ça va être du
style télégraphique vu le nombre de
questions bon il en reste beaucoup mais
c'est ce que je comprends
je te laisse dire un mot sur les 44
millions oui donc sur les 44 millions je
rappelle que
nous avions pour objectif de recruter
4000 conseillers numérique et que nous
en avons recruté 3600 donc comme vous le
pressentiez les budgets alloués en 2023
sont des budgets visant à pérenniser les
conseillers numériques déjà recrutés
la question qui consiste à nous dire
mais quel est vous faire après
on va y travailler en 2023 aujourd'hui
maison France service et conseiller
numérique font un travail absolument
remarquable de lutte contre l'isolement
les territoires ruraux je fais partie de
ceux qui somme intimement convaincus sur
le fait que continuer avec encore une
fois mes enfants services ça fonctionne
très bien donc laissons-nous l'année
2023 puisqu'on a pu obtenir la
pérennisation de ces de du financement
de ces conseillers numériques pour voir
ce que l'on fait ensuite
sur les refuges on attend une étude sur
un refuge marin qu'on devrait avoir au
début de l'année parce qu'on aura la
question qui va après qui est celle des
cétacé etc et on devrait avoir fin mars
je pense les éléments qui nous
permettent de mesurer
la question de la pérennisation des
dispositifs elle est aussi au cœur des
discussions que nous avons avec les
Circassiens puisque une partie de ces
refuges vont pouvoir accueillir les
animaux sauvages j'ai pris le temps de
les rencontrer avec Olivier Grégoire il
y a quelques jours à Bercy pour discuter
des barèmes d'indemnisation et de des
dispositifs pour permettre la cessation
effective d'activité et la manière dont
tout ça va atterrir
c'est dans la SNB pardon c'est dans la
stratégie nationale de la biodiversité
2030 mais les lignes ne figurent pas au
PLF 2023 on est encore sur des crédits
pour le moment qui vont être abondés de
manière marginale peut-être aussi par le
loto de la biodiversité qui a priori
voudrait en faire un de ses objets mais
bon le vrai sujet là dessus il arrive
mais il arrive un peu plus tard sur le
fond vert
2 milliards d'euros
c'est effectivement le nouveau montant
nous ne voulons pas d'appeler à projet
nous ne voulons pas d'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt on imagine
déconcentrer ces sommes à l'échelle des
préfectures de département
de manière ensuite à ce que la
répartition soit la plus efficace et la
plus rapide possible pour accompagner
l'ensemble du territoire c'est un
nouveau dispositif on part de zéro pas
tout à fait on part de 300 millions
parce que pour être totalement
transparent il y avait un fond free à
hauteur de 300 millions qui
disparaissait avec le plan de relance
normalement il y avait zéro là il y a 2
milliards qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec
faire ce que les élus
nous demandent pour que ce soit bon pour
le climat
en clair
tout ce qui atténuation tout ce qui est
adaptation tout ce qui est biodiversité
c'est dedans
on a fait des enveloppes que nous
jugeons prévisionnel
on considère que 150 millions d'euros
par exemple pour les territoires qui
sont ZFE compte tenu des besoins
c'est sans doute à la hauteur de l'enjeu
l'érosion du trait de côte qui concerne
aujourd'hui un nombre important de
communes et d'autres sont en train de se
poser la question c'est 20% du littoral
nous souhaitons que ça fasse partie des
critères qui puisse bénéficier là aussi
au dispositif la rénovation des
éclairages publics la déminéralisation
d'une cour d'école la plantation d'arbre
pour aller faire des îlots de fraîcheur
tout ça est dedans ma thèse c'est que on
va assez vite avoir suffisamment de
demandes pour prouver que une enveloppe
annuelle de ce montant est à la hauteur
des enjeux voire à la hauteur d'une
partie des enjeux
mais on a aussi un autre sujet c'est
comment les collectivités réorientent de
toute façon massivement leur crédit sur
des priorités climatiques à partir du
moment où on considère qu'il y a une
urgence à agir ce qui explique la mise
en place des budgets verts pour qu'on
ait un outil de discussion avec elle et
là l'objectif c'est d'atterrir en 2023
et on a souhaité une vraie méthode de
co-construction autrement dit ce sont
les associations d'élus qui vont nous
faire remonter leur proposition de
maquette par strate
département région ville sur ce que
pourrait être ces budgets verts ce qui
montre aussi que c'est pas la main de
Bercy mais que ça doit demain devenir un
outil de discussion environnementale
pour regarder comment on accélère
ensemble
sur la décarbonation en 2035 est-ce que
c'est crédible
la politique c'est pas de se demander ce
qui est possible c'est d'essayer de
rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
s'il y a des gens qui considèrent
qui a un sujet de réchauffement
climatique il faut bien qu'on prenne des
mesures pour lutter contre les énergies
fossiles oui c'est compliqué oui on a
besoin de métaux rares de cuivre de
lithium oui on a des enjeux en termes
d'équipement du territoire mais le coût
de l'inaction mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il est considérable on
commence à le pays avec la guerre en
Ukraine
on a la bouche tous quelle que soit nos
opinions la conviction que la
souveraineté c'est quelque chose de
souhaitable notamment sur ces sujets
tant qu'à faire ne pas dépendre de
source d'énergie que nous ne produisons
pas quand on voit l'importance de ces
énergies ça a du sens et c'est bien la
raison pour laquelle on a besoin d'abord
d'éviter de gaspiller c'est le nom de la
sobriété ensuite d'être capable d'avoir
des sources d'énergie qui soit
alternatives et heureusement qu'on a le
nucléaire
ça permet à notre pays d'être en avance
sur la seule partie énergie en termes de
décarbonation et de disposer d'une
énergie qui soit pilotable puisque les
intermittents ne suffisent pas la preuve
c'est qu'on rouvre les centrales à
charbon là où on a fermé les centrales
nucléaires et je pense que le jugement
des générations futures sera terrible
pour ceux qui auront fait la guerre en
nucléaire sans se rendre compte qu'ils
ont ainsi contribué pour partie à nous
détourner d'un moyen efficace de la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
sur le loup question hyper compliquée
mais le début de l'année qui arrive et
est un moment de vérité
parce que c'est le moment où nous devons
réviser le plan loup la précédente
version avait expliqué qu'il était
souhaitable d'atteindre au moins 500
individus pour que l'espèce puisse être
considérée comme étant réintroduites
mais contrairement à ce que j'entends
jamais cette stratégie n'avait dit qu'il
y avait un maximum
nous considérons aujourd'hui qu'il y a
plus de 900 loups sur le territoire leur
présence qui augmente d'une centaine
d'individus par an fait que de nouveaux
territoires sont confrontés aujourd'hui
à la présence du loup et que c'est
extraordinairement compliqué dans des
territoires qui n'y étaient pas habitués
c'est déjà pas simple dans des
territoires qui étaient habitués mais on
s'aperçoit qu'au bout de quelques années
il y a quand même des choses qui
marchent plus que d'autres et qu'on
finit par savoir comment vivre avec
nous sommes en train de travailler avec
le ministère de l'agriculture sur trois
ou quatre directions
d'abord nous ne faisons pas le nombre de
tirs de prélèvement autorisé par les
textes 19%. parce qu'on nous indique que
dans un certain nombre de cas les
procédures sont beaucoup trop complexes
et donc puisque les 19% ont été posés
comme étant un élément de l'équilibre
qu'on atteigne au moins ces 19%, ne
devrait choquer personne et donc on nous
dit qu'il y a des pistes de
simplification sur les frontières
administratives sur les attaques
multiples j'entre pas dans le détail on
a un deuxième sujet sur l'indemnisation
la procédure est complexe les
agriculteurs se plaignent qu'en
particulier
un animal disparu ne soit pas indemnisé
alors qu'il peut y avoir dans un certain
nombre de cas des moments où on ne
retrouve pas la carcasse et donc ça
ajoute un préjudice économique bon on a
le sujet du temps que ça prend pour les
agents de l'OV on a le sujet des
multiples prédations on a la question
des équipements on a la question du
soutien louvetier on a la question de la
deuxième équipe au FB qui va être mise
en place tous ces sujets là c'est pas
par facilité je voulais liste pour vous
montrer que nous les connaissons et que
nous les travaillions avec Bérengère
Couillard mais je vous indique que c'est
plutôt au début de l'année prochaine et
que nous sommes en discussion avec nos
partenaires européens on n'est pas les
seuls à avoir à introduit le loup et la
Convention de Berne elle est d'échelle
européenne
sur la question des agences de l'eau ce
qui était valable en 2022 pourrait tout
à fait lettre à nouveau en 2023
avec des compléments de crédit autorisés
en cours d'année là aussi un minimum de
méthodes on regarde ce que sont les
besoins financiers et ensuite on regarde
comment on complète les 2,2 milliards
d'euros d'autorisation qui sont prévus
dans le cadre du PLF il vous a pas
échappé que les agences de l'eau avaient
une trésorerie de 500 à 600 millions
d'euros qui seraient immédiatement
mobilisable au moins pour partie et qui
explique que qu'on a déjà puisé dedans
en partie le cuivre je n'y reviens pas
plutôt je n'y reviens pas parce que
c'est le même sujet que le lithium et
qu'on a besoin d'un plan plus exactement
on a besoin d'une stratégie d'accès à
ces métaux précieux qui ne nous rendent
pas dépendants demain
et on voit bien là aussi l'exercice
l'acceptabilité légisment la
sécurisation et les besoins qui peuvent
aller avec c'est bien pour ça que la
question de la sobriété de la taille
moyen de du poids moyen des véhicules et
de leur empreinte doit être au cœur des
différentes stratégies
sur la les grands enjeux que vous
décrivez microplastiques etc le
Parlement européen dans le suivi de la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne a voté un texte ultra
ambitieux pour lutter contre la
déforestation importée
quand on va faire nos courses dans les
supermarchés nous contribuons à hauteur
de 16% de la déforestation du Brésil ou
du bassin du Congo
toute l'idée c'est demain de ne plus
acheter de produits pour lesquels les
importateurs ne pourront pas prouver
qu'ils n'ont pas été cultivés grâce à la
déforestation avec une première liste de
produits et la définition d'une ambition
il y a des questions sur lesquelles je
n'entre pas est-ce que les tourbières et
les savanes sont concernés et sur les
types de produits les versions les plus
ambitieuses intégrant les activités
financières au périmètre du vote du
Parlement européen donc tout l'enjeu
c'est maintenant d'arriver en trilogue à
se mettre d'accord entre la Commission
les États et le Parlement mais nous
sommes pour un compromis qui soit
ambitieux parce que demain ça veut dire
éviter aussi de regarder nos émissions
ou nos pratiques mais de prendre des
décisions qui aboutiraient à alimenter
ailleurs ce que dont nous ne voulons
plus ici et ce qui est vrai pour la
déforestation mais pour le plastique la
France pour le coup est vraiment en tête
des pays qui ont pris des décisions
extrêmement ambitieuses en revanche
cette question du plastique qui devrait
faire l'objet d'une convention
spécifique avec nous le souhaitons des
interdictions à l'horizon 2040 ne sont
absolument pas à la minute où on se
parle partager par tous les pays du
monde et la progression est timide
sur les
pesticides ou sur les traces chimiques
le sujet c'est riche la commission vient
d'envoyer un signal qui ne convient pas
qui consiste à dire qu'elle souhaite
décaler la révision
de la directive on s'est retrouvé un
certain nombre de pays
l'Allemagne la Suède la Finlande la
Norvège même si elle n'appartient pas à
l'Union européenne elle fait partie de
groupe informel pour regarder comment on
progresse sur les questions climatiques
en marche du sommeil européen il y a dix
jours pour au contraire rappeler la
nécessité qu'il y a à adopter un cadre
en 2023 avant les élections européennes
plus contraignant que celui qui existe
d'autant la révision de la directive
n'est pas d'application immédiate mais
qu'elle est d'application 5 ans après le
moment on l'a arrêté donc il y a urgence
à faire en sorte de durcir nos règles y
compris pour que l'industrie chimique
puisse se préparer à ses évolutions et
qu'à la fin on nous disent pas on n'a
pas le temps il faut décaler la date des
faits ou imaginaire nouveau moratoire
c'est l'inverse qu'on souhaite c'est
poser le cap suffisamment tôt pour
éviter ce type de déconvenue
merci la parole est arrivé point trop
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la secrétaire d'État je
veux revenir sur les Ederer qui vous
permettez puisque
on a auditionné madame cailleux ministre
des collectivités locales la semaine
dernière et je lui ai posé la question
bien évidemment alors je sais pas si
c'est dans son
secteur mais avec madame la secrétaire
d'État vous devez partager elle nous a
dit être favorable
continuer donc mettre en place continuer
par les mettre en place mais au moins
les améliorer ces Ederer et moi je
voudrais savoir quel est votre sentiment
sur le sujet parce que il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur le terrain
par rapport à une volonté peut-être de
les supprimer puisque on a l'impression
que Bercy est plutôt défavorable alors
que ça coûte 300 millions d'euros pour
la ruralité c'est peut-être pas grand
chose par rapport à tout ce qu'on peut
verser dans d'autres domaines et il y a
aussi certains députés qui trouvent que
les ZRR ne sont pas suffisamment
[Musique]
comment dire il y a pas suffisamment de
retombées et que ça serait pas forcément
la bonne solution
moi je dois vous dire que on a fait un
rapport avec mes collègues Bernard
delcroé et Frédéric espagneiac
où on a mis au moins une dizaine de
préconisations avec le changement de
critères etc et on a au sein de la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
lancer une étude d'impact et de
d'évaluation pour voir quelles étaient
les solutions pour améliorer d'abord
préserver les Ederer mais aussi les
renforcer et améliorer le principe alors
moi ma question elle est simple est-ce
que vous êtes certain de l'avenir des et
derrière deuxième question est-ce que
vous vous tiendrez compte de ce qu'a
fait le Sénat
en habitant par exemple ceux qui ont
travaillé sur le sujet ce qui ne
semblerait quand même logique et
important ça c'était ma première
question deuxième question ça concerne
alors c'est la petite hydroélectricité
alors je sais que c'est pas tout à fait
dans votre domaine mais ça l'est quand
même par rapport à sur le terrain une
volonté
et de l'administration
de d'être assez défavorable à cette
petite hydroélectricité
du fait de la soi-disant la continuité
écologique qui qui perdure avec le texte
de loi sur le sur ce point il y a
quelques années et moi j'aimerais savoir
quel est votre sentiment sur cette
petite israélicité parce qu'il y a des
choses à faire valoir il y a de
l'énergie à pouvoir mettre en place pour
des des secteurs ruraux notamment et je
pense que ça me paraît important et puis
troisième point c'est sur la politique
de l'eau qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
effectivement je crois que il faut
relativiser les choses vous allez on a
parlé de des canalisations d'eau potable
qui s'enfuyantes c'est un milliard de
mètres cubes d'eau perdus en France
aujourd'hui
un milliard de mètres cubes d'eau c'est
l'équivalent de 450 000 hectares
irrigués et je voudrais qu'on relative
des choses par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
dimanche dernier par rapport aux
réserves de substitution qui me sont à
mon avis
indispensables à mettre en place si on
veut garder notre rupture vivante sur
certains secteurs et moi ma question
elle est simple est-ce que vous vous
engagez
à ne pas céder à la pression de ces
activistes qu'on voit fleurir un peu
partout ces mêmes activistes
anti-nucléaires qui nous ont fait perdre
notre indépendance énergétique ben oui
mais d'accord mais monsieur le Président
chacun a le droit de s'exprimer on a
attendu comme beaucoup donc
laissez-nous le temps de comme d'autres
l'ont fait à s'exprimer je pense que
c'est important de parler de ce sujet
qui a été dont il était question tout à
l'heure au Q âgé et il me paraît
important de vous engager à ne pas céder
à cette pression parce que on voit bien
que on nous emmène dans le mur avec tout
ça c'est notre indépendance énergétique
où on voit bien que maintenant il va
falloir apporter de l'énergie
d'Allemagne faite à partir de charbon et
puis demain ça va être la dépendance
alimentaire
où on voit qu'on perd du terrain et
aujourd'hui pour garder cette
indépendance alimentaire il faut de
l'eau on a besoin d'eau pour produire
des semences qui sont produites en
Ukraine notamment pour produire des
cultures qui nous viennent aujourd'hui
qui sont importés qui sont des cultures
parfois
OGM dont on ne veut pas dans notre pays
ou des cultures qui sont traitées au
glyphosate donc il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut est-ce que vous êtes prêts à vous
engager sur
à ne pas céder à cette pression que nous
voyons fleurir de jour en jour
merci merci je vais donner la parole à
Jean-Pierre corviset puis après je vais
demander à Guillaume je voulais devenir
président parce que j'ai un rendez-vous
chez le président de Larcher bien merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur Miss
madame secrétaire d'État une double
question la semaine dernière votre
collègue madame cailleux devant cette
commission
je vais attendre que chevrolier
président
oui monsieur Miss madame secrétaire
d'État la semaine dernière votre
collègue madame cailleux durant cette
commission dans le cas de la loizanne
nous annoncé que les projets nationaux
et supranationaux ne verraient pas leur
compensation de surface impactées sur
les collectivités ainsi
le canal senor
n'aurait pas un reporter sa compensation
de
2200 hectares sur les communes
environnantes pouvez-vous nous confirmer
cette proposition faite par Madame
Cayeux parce qu'elle vous a cité la
semaine dernière qu'en pensez-vous faire
d'une annonce officielle sur cette non
compensation par les communes aux
alentours quant aux communes rurales qui
voudraient faire du développement
urbain dans le cas de la loizanne il
existe des possibilités pour elle c'est
à dire les États en abordant manifeste
c'est l'article 98 de la loi 3DS qui
prend ses origines dans la PPL de
Jacques mesard et qu'on avait voté ici
au Sénat ainsi de 20 ans à 10 ans les
communes peuvent récupérer des biens en
état manifeste d'abandon seulement
malheureusement cela coûte cher à
démolir et en revanche alors qu'il y a
des très grandes surfaces pouvez-vous
imaginer une DETR spécifique parce que
parfois en attendant de dire ça sera la
dotr mais il y a déjà tellement de
demandes financières une DETR spécifique
de façon à ce que c'est comme une rurale
puisse continuer leur développement
urbain sans venir préempter des terrains
agricoles ma deuxième question sera dans
le cadre de l'eau comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure mon collègue chevrolier moi dans
les hauts de France les hydrogéologues
annoncent d'ici 2040 une baisse de 30 %
du niveau de l'eau potable dans la nappe
mais ce serait encore gérable
malheureusement la baisse de 30% du
niveau entraînerait une augmentation de
50% des polluants dans la nappe or mon
territoire a déjà bien pollué par le
père perclorate d'ammonium avec des
conséquences sur les femmes enceintes et
les nourrissons donc percera des moyens
qui provient de la poudre à canon
allemande comment a pu le dire tout à
l'heure au qager mon collègue
Jean-François Rapin un siècle après les
Allemands nous embêtent encore ainsi que
l'augmentation d'autres polluants
naturels dans la nappe pensez-vous
monsieur le ministre envisagez une
mission sur cette thématique comment
d'ici 2020 continuer à avoir de l'eau de
la nappe dans un état satisfaisant et
par rapport à en partie au polluant
naturel qui serait dedans voilà
merci je donnais la parole à Eric gold
pierre mesdevielle et Stéphane demillet
on laissera ensuite les ministres
répondre merci merci président donc ma
question moi concernait à la fois la
ruralité et la transition écho donc je
vous laisse le choix de qui va répondre
on discute cette semaine au Sénat un
texte sur l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables on se cense les
collectivités territoriales ont un rôle
majeur à jouer dans la promotion de la
maîtrise de l'énergie et le
développement des énergies renouvelables
depuis qu'elle dispose également
généralement d'un important patrimoine
bâti dans certaines toitures peuvent
être équipées de photovoltaïques si je
prends l'exemple du département du
Puy-de-Dôme de nombreuses élus sont
lancés dans la démarche en installant
des panneaux donc sur la salle des fêtes
leur école ou autre bâtiments alors les
services de l'État imposent la création
d'un budget annexe pour les mouvements
financiers qui ont découle quel que soit
le montant des sommes perçues
ceci est d'autant moins compréhensible
que l'État a accepté beaucoup de
simplification dans la gestion communale
avec par exemple toilettage des régies
de recettes la suppression de
l'obligation des centres communaux
d'action sociale dans les communes de
moins de 1500 habitants ou encore la
possibilité de déroger au budget annexe
pour la vente de bois alors la DGFiP et
la DGCL saisit sur cette obligation de
budget annexes n'ont pas encore apporté
de réponses avez-vous vous des éléments
de réponse à apporter aux collectivités
parfois et souvent les plus modestes
d'ailleurs qui s'engagent pleinement
dans cette accélération des énergies
renouvelables je vous remercie
merci Pierre et deviel merci Président
je suis le ministre même la secrétaire
d'État nous avons eu de nombreux débats
au sein lors du vote de la loi climat
résilience concernant les zones à faible
émission de mobilité dite ZFE leur mise
en place arrive très vite il y a plus de
dizaine d'agglomérations concernées par
ce dispositif l'ont déjà mis en œuvre
comme comme Toulouse madame la
secrétaire d'État un premier comité
ministériel a eu lieu la semaine
dernière quels sont les conclusions que
vous en tirez en suivant des questions
concernent le fond vert mais elle a été
posée par Angèle Préville dont je me
contenterai d'une invitation on a évoqué
brièvement la décarbonation de
l'aviation je vais coproduire avec un
député de la Haute-Garonne de mon
département un rapport à la demande de
lopex dès le mois de janvier 2023 sur ce
sujet de décarbonation et c'est pas une
question de la question c'est plutôt une
invitation à venir visiter une start-up
qui s'appelle aura Hero qui a déjà 130
précommandes d'avion hybride nous avions
électriques et une visite bien sûr à
Airbus ou c'est toujours intéressant
puisque l'avion a hydrogène va bientôt
voler
merci Stéphane Demigny oui merci
monsieur le Président deux questions
rapides monsieur le ministre Christophe
Béchu je voudrais reformuler la question
de Monsieur corbizet non pas qu'elle ait
été mal posée mais ça vous montrera
l'importance de la question
confirmez-vous que les 2500 hectares du
canal senor Europe ne rentrerons pas
dans le calcul du zan une réponse
monocyllebique composée par exemple de
trois voyelles nous suffira largement
une deuxième question pour la ministre
Dominique Faure en zone rurale un
généraliste couvre en moyenne 30 km²
contre 5 km² dans les bassins de vie
urbains cette différence est loin de
s'expliquer par la seule densité de la
de la population et les conséquences
sont sans appel d'ailleurs l'association
des mers ruraux de France nous la
rappeler récemment avec un constat
alarmant d'une aggravation des écarts
d'espérance de vie dans les territoires
ruraux il est véritablement
urgent de mettre l'ordre des médecins
autour de la table pour
penser
urgemment la démocratie sanitaire de
notre pays parce que je crains qu'un
jour nous ayons des gilets jaunes de la
santé dans le pays madame la ministre la
lutte contre l'abandon médical de nos
territoires ruraux est-ce bien une des
priorités de vos priorités
merci madame la secrétaire d'État
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
pour compléter mes propos sur les ZRR
tout à l'heure et pour répondre à votre
question est-ce qu'on s'engage
aujourd'hui non la première ministre
nous a mandaté pour travailler sur les
ZRR est-ce que je suis personnellement
motivé déterminé convaincu de leur
utilité oui donc parce que Christophe
Béchu a bien voulu me confier cette
mission parce que nous avons pu confier
à Monsieur filizeau ce travail je suis
déterminé avec l'aide de la DGCL comme
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure à
conduire un certain nombre de travaux
qui vont nous amener au printemps avec
des propositions et pourquoi pas avec
des et derrière à deux vitesses comme
c'est proposé dans le rapport et dans
les 14 propositions des sénateurs
espagnols
bon moi j'ai été intéressé par deux et
donc nous avons déjà conduit un certain
nombre de simulations je vous l'ai dit
notre calendrier dans l'hypothèse ou
quand nous aurons travaillé avec nous
aurions voir la première ministre et que
les ZRR pourront bien donc n'ont pas
être renouvelés on part sur un nouveau
dispositif dans l'hypothèse où ça serait
validé voilà qui démarrait en janvier
2014 peut-être à deux vitesses je trouve
cela pertinent et avec à la fois un
texte de loi obligatoire au printemps
qui nous permettrait de mettre les
budgets nécessaires dans le PLF 2024 et
qui devrait donner lieu à des articles
du PLF et du plfs en 2023 pour 2024 et
les années suivantes voilà le calendrier
tel que nous l'avons en tête voilà la
façon dont nous travaillons dès
aujourd'hui je suis une école
nous avons été saisis par Frédéric
espagneiac et Bernard Delcros d'une
demande pour qu'on les reçoivent pour
qu'ils nous remette leur rapport et ça a
eu lieu il y a quelques jours
le rapport demandé à la suite de la
mission Castex
dans lequel d'autres parlementaires donc
on a officiellement reçu ce rapport et
donc il y a pas beaucoup de meilleures
preuves de notre volonté de travailler
avec le Sénat
mais il y a tellement de rapports
[Musique]
on a repris tous les tous les rapports
et l'engagement que nous prenons c'est
évidemment de travailler avec le Sénat
et de faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
visibilité à une distance raisonnable
des élections sénatoriales pour ne pas
qu'on aille agiter des craintes
injustifiées partout sur le territoire
sur le sujet monsieur le sénateur des
déserts médicaux oui ce sujet est au
cœur on va dire de mes trois ou quatre
priorités les aiderrai en font partie on
a plusieurs axes de travail un que vous
connaissez déjà très brièvement c'est
cette quatrième année d'internat oui
l'ordre des médecins est associé par
l'intermédiaire du professeur
stefanoustric et un groupe de travail
qui a été lancé le 23 septembre par
François Braun moi j'ai confiance même
si les étudiants considèrent qu'une
année de médecine générale
supplémentaire ne les amuse pas beaucoup
et passer de 9 à 10 ans mais ça les met
sur un pied d'égalité avec tous les
spécialistes autres parce que la
médecine générale est considérée par les
spécialistes de médecine générale comme
une discipline qui mériterait cette
quatrième année ça c'est le premier acte
le second c'est le travail que nous
faisons et que fait surtout le ministre
de la Santé avec les hôpitaux de
proximité la prise de conscience est
totale le travail est quotidien et c'est
un de mes sujets moi ce sur quoi je
travaille c'est une bonne pratique que
je rencontre sur le terrain et que je
partage régulièrement avec Agnès Firmin
le Baudot c'est-à-dire le mélange de
médecins salariés parce que parfois on
entend dire ils veulent être salarié ils
ne veulent pas le sujet n'est pas il le
veulent ils le vole pas le sujet de le
proposer aujourd'hui à Vic-en-Bigorre on
a par exemple une expérimentation qui
commence à se développer ou le président
de l'interco avait des murs les a
rénover grâce à de la DETR et accueille
deux médecins salariés et deux médecins
libéraux un pôle néonatal s'est créé un
cabinet de radiologie s'est créé dans
ces mêmes locaux on a là au cœur de
trois départements et en zone très
rurale ce qu'on fait de mieux en matière
de radiologie de Paul néonatal et de
médecine générale ça recommence à se
reproduire pourquoi parce que le déficit
généré par les médecins salariés et
remboursés par l'ARS personne ne le sait
donc je vous dis ça pour que vous qui
êtes en contact avec les présidents
d'intercaux vous n'attendiez pas que
j'ai fait cette belle plateforme de
partage d'expérience un peu dans tous
les domaines pour dire au maire porter
des projets la RS n'a pas besoin ça au
début porter un business plan sur la
base de murs dont vous disposez et ça va
fonctionner autre bonne pratique je
constate pour des mères qui au milieu
d'une maison française et d'un CCAS ont
un local et bien ils prennent leur
petite valise ils vont voir une dizaine
de spécialistes qui sont pour certains à
50-70 100 km il leur disent une
demi-journée par mois 12 rendez-vous je
vous prends les rendez-vous avec mon
accueil du CCAS ou de la maison France
service j'ai des exemples extrêmement
intéressants ou neuf spécialistes
viennent une demi-journée par mois se
rendre dans le petit village en
environnement rural on voit bien que ce
sujet nous l'avons pris à bras le corps
moi je l'ai comme vous l'avez compris en
transversal mon rôle est de partager
toutes les bonnes pratiques que je vois
à la télémédecine elle est aujourd'hui
au cœur de nos réflexions pourquoi parce
que on a de vrai
on va dire équipement produit
industriellement fabriqué en France qui
permettent aux médecins à distance
d'abord évidemment de voir son patient
alors que dans rater les consultations
aujourd'hui on ne la qu'en audio mais en
même temps de transmettre toutes les
constantes ça se traduit par un chariot
avec une infirmière à côté ça se traduit
par une cabine qui se ferme dans lequel
on parle avec son médecin pendant 20
minutes et où le médecin à toutes les
constantes du patient donc des
expérimentations réussie il y en a
beaucoup moi ce qui m'attriste c'est de
voir comment nous allons faire pour les
partager en attendant que le numerus
clausus qui lui a été libéré mais fasse
son effet qu'on voit arriver un peu plus
de médecins en attendant que la loi
permette aux infirmières au kiné au
sage-femme d'exercer un certain nombre
de pratiques médicales et de pharmaciens
sa tante de pratique médicale voilà pour
les déserts médicaux j'espère vous avoir
convaincu que on est au travail sur le
sujet
ne fera pas partie
du décompte territorial de la Région
Haute France il reste un débat Xavier
Bertrand plaide pour que
ça soit sorti du compteur
d'artificialisation du pays ça n'est pas
la ligne du ministère de la transition
écologique je dis on va faire un compter
à part des grands projets nationaux
qu'on divisera entre tous les
territoires pour ne pas qu'il y en ait
un qui porte seul le poids mais dire
cette Europe c'est pas de
l'artificialisation ou la LGV Toulouse -
Bordeaux c'est pas de
l'artificialisation ça veut dire qu'on
modifie nous-mêmes la trajectoire que
qui a été fixée il y a un an et demi
donc l'idée c'est bien de partager ça
entre toutes les régions et donc que les
2200 hectares j'avais pas 2400 j'avais
2200 mais je me battrai pas que les 2200
hectares soient divisés entre toutes les
régions françaises en fait on va
additionner grand projet nationaux
il y en a pas tant que ça on va les
sortir et ensuite on va recalculer les
enveloppes régionales en ayant enlevé
cette petite part divisée par les 10 ans
c'est ce que je proposerai j'attire
votre attention que comme ça n'est pas
conforme à la loi ça nécessitera un vote
deuxièmement les bassines
je veux dire un mot extrêmement rapide
tous les projets se valent pas
le premier sujet c'est comment on a une
agriculture qui consomme moins d'eau
c'est le premier tout court pour nous
tous parce que la vérité c'est que un
moment une retenue qu'elle soit
colinéaire ou quel pompe il faut qu'on
ait de la source or si on s'illusionne
sur le fait qu'on aura demain la même
ressource à disposition on risque de
faire de mauvais investissements donc
l'évolution de la pratique elle est
nécessaire une fois qu'on a dit ça une
fois qu'on a dit ça
bien sûr que les retenus c'est pas la
solution mais c'est une partie de la
solution et en l'espèce quand on a des
études scientifiques quand on a des
accords quand y compris des associations
environnementales signent et qu'après on
a des radicaux et des jusqu'au-boutistes
c'est la cause qui est menacée et
franchement ce qui s'est passé et
d'autant plus grave que le territoire
sur lequel nous sommes polyculture
élevage la canalisation coupée qui
désire une exploitation familiale à
proximité l'image que ça donne vis-à-vis
de l'extérieur
parce que si ces gens-là considèrent que
Monsieur Jadot n'est pas écologiste ça
donne une petite idée du prisme avec
lequel il regarde le reste de la société
et on ne fera pas la transition
écologique contre les gens
j'ajoute que il faut qu'on se méfie
d'une forme d'extrémisme quel que soit
son domaine qui aurait uniquement les
yeux basés sur ce que nous faisons chez
nous
parce que si je me base que sur la
réduction de nos émissions bah ferment
toutes les usines et on sera super bon
en décarbonation mais si en parallèle on
continue à acheter des produits on
aggravera notre situation donc c'est
bien un double phénomène dans lequel il
faut qu'on soit vertueux ici et qu'on
ait des mécanismes carbone à nos
frontières ça n'est pas un gros mot
c'est indispensable pour réussir une
transition
n'accepte pas de faire entrer des
produits qui sont moins vertueux que
ceux qu'on fabrique on peut appeler ça
du protectionnisme en l'espèce c'est une
forme de protectionnisme climatique si
c'est pour empêcher la déforestation ou
l'arrivée de produits avec des
perturbateurs endocriniens à l'intérieur
parce que j'ai pas répondu sur ce point
qui est crucial 40 pièces de textile en
moyenne achetées par français et par an
indépendamment de la manière dont c'est
fait quand vous savez
l'eau qu'il faut pour produire des
vêtements en textile vous mesurez là
aussi l'intérêt qui aurait en termes de
sobriété
sur les panneaux photovoltaïques très
sincèrement je ne sais pas répondre à
cette question mais je sais une chose
c'est que faire un budget annexe pour
les énergies renouvelables
c'est le meilleur moyen d'accélérer sans
être tenu par des ratios contre les par
la Cour des comptes
et que pour avoir et c'est un témoignage
personnel monté une SPL
uniquement pour permettre à des communes
de solvabilité leurs investissements
dans les énergies renouvelables avec une
mise de départ extrêmement faible quand
j'étais président du Département ça nous
a permis d'aller accompagner dans plein
d'endroits du territoire des projets
photovoltaïques et même un projet éolien
complété par des habitants avec un une
cotisation
et
l'initiative de Joël Bigot quand il
était à la fois mon vice-président dans
l'agglomération et le maire d'une très
belle commune la plus grande
photovoltaïque de tout le grand ouest
qui a été faite en passant par cette
société ce qui nous a permis de pas
dégrader nos ratios et de pouvoir
emprunter vite de quoi réaliser les
choses mais sur les petits projets le
plus petit projet qu'on a porté c'est 63
mètres carrés pour le toit d'investir de
foot à Cheviré le rouge on aurait été
incapable de le faire tout seul c'est
parce qu'on l'a mis dans une espl qu'on
a pu moyenner les tarifs d'achat et
faire en sorte de pouvoir retrouver un
dispositif qui tienne qui tienne la
route enfin
sur les annonces et des feux
un comité ministériel tous les six mois
un référent interministériel qui soit
connecté à l'intérieur pour les
questions de verbalisation à la santé
pour les questions d'observation mais
aussi à Bercy pour la question du
travail des artisans et de la logistique
urbaine parce qu'il faut que les feux
intègrent ce type de règles et qu'on
envoie des signaux qui sont à peu près
les mêmes deux groupes de travail un sur
l'harmonisation logistique l'autre sur
l'accessibilité sociale et un certain
nombre d'annonces très concrètes les
millions du fond vert les 1000 euros de
surprime qui ne sont plus soumises à
condition de réciprocité et l'ouverture
de l'État pour garantir les prêts à taux
zéro en en précisant les règles telles
que j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire et le
fait que le rétrofit fera bien partie de
ce qui sera finançable dans le cadre des
aides qui valent pour les particuliers
mais il faut construire la filière pour
aller très très vite voilà ce que je
peux dire
pardon petite hydroélectricité même
chose je suis mal à l'aise parce que
j'aurais peur de dire une bêtise et que
quand je connais pas bien un sujet je
préfère m'abstenir totalement et
là-dessus je préfère m'abstenir parce
que j'ai lu des choses contradictoires
pour être tout à fait honnête
vous aurez l'occasion de revenir
dernière série de questions Gilbert Luc
de winas oui merci Guillaume même les
Minismes monsieur le ministre en début
de rencontre monsieur le ministre vous
avez rappelé deux piliers essentiels
transports et logement et en principe
les logements ça chauffe si l'hiver veut
bien arriver et depuis 2021 il y a une
augmentation très importante des
installations de chaudière à granulés ou
des poêles à granulés soutenus
d'ailleurs par l'État grâce au
dispositif ma prime rénove
et la production de ces granulés
elle aussi considérablement augmenté la
filière même prévoit une augmentation
encore plus importante d'ici 4 ans et
cette production nationale est complétée
par de l'importation qui a pris une
place très importante depuis le début de
l'année depuis début 2022 le prix annulé
a subi une inflation
sans précédent et constater sur le
terrain à plus de 150%. donc j'ai trois
questions si l'augmentation des coûts de
production de ces granulés et la hausse
des importations peuvent en être la
cause il faut aussi ajouter une marche
qui me semble excessive que pratique et
distributeurs dans un contexte de fortes
tensions of demande
quel intervention directe de l'État
auprès des revendeurs et producteurs
pensez-vous mettre en oeuvre pour calmer
la situation qui semble s'emballer y
a-t-il pas un besoin de libérer des
stocks constatés chez les fabricants en
France et dont on ne comprend pas la
signification de cette période de
tension d'approvisionnement
l'échec énergie constitue une réponse
insuffisante sur leur montant que sur le
nombre de bénéficiaires quel autre
mesure sont prévues pour favoriser des
énergies plus respectueuses de
l'environnement
merci Joël Bigot
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez compris la semaine dernière nous
avons audité madame cailloux j'avais
posé une question à laquelle j'avais pas
eu de réponse et Madame caillou m'avait
répondu que c'était sans doute monsieur
Béchu qui avait la réponse donc je la
réitère
je la réitère depuis le départ d'Arnaud
le roi de l'ADEME la présidence de
l'ADEME est vacances et à ce jour il n'y
a pas de président donc et donc est-ce
que la réponse est de votre ressort ça
c'est la première chose parce que ça
nous intéresse parce qu'il s'agit pas
simplement d'une question de casting
dont vous avez compris que ce sont des
sujets parfois sensibles il s'agit aussi
de d'une volonté politique c'est un acte
politique est-ce que c'est la volonté du
gouvernement de ne pas renouveler le
président d'une agence d'accompagnement
à la transition à l'adaptation à
laquelle les territoires sont très
attachés je suis membre du CA de la dame
et je peux vous assurer que cette
situation jette une certaine confusion
dans les services de cet instant sur la
ligne défendue par le gouvernement en
matière de projet
en dernier lieu je souhaite vous poser
une question sur l'examen du projet de
loi de finance lors du dernier texte
budgétaire de cet été j'avais porté un
amendement visant à conditionner les
aides publiques à nos engagements
climatiques je pense que les temps sont
mûrs maintenant pour instaurer cette
écho conditionnalité et que l'État
puisse inciter puissamment le secteur
privé dans une démarche de planification
écologique un arrêté pris fin 2021
d'ores et déjà été pris concernant les
entreprises dont l'état est actionnaire
est-ce que cette dimension chère à la
Convention citoyenne pour le climat sera
comprise dans la feuille de route
environnementale du gouvernement et
faire ainsi de la France une nation
verte selon l'expression même de madame
la Première ministre merci monsieur
madame monsieur le ministre merci Nicole
Bonnefoy
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
monsieur critère d'État en 2019 avec
notre collègue Michel baspard nous
avions tous les deux remis un rapport
sur les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique plus particulièrement sur les
aléas climatiques et leurs multiplicité
en nombre mais aussi en intensité ce qui
était exceptionnelle il y a quelques
années ne l'est plus aujourd'hui et nous
pour ma part je suis à l'issue de cette
mission
à l'origine d'une proposition de loi
pour réformer le régime des catastrophes
naturelles puisque évidemment ça
multiplicité de ces aléas avait une
conséquence importante sur le régime des
catastrophes naturelles et donc dans ma
proposition de loi qui a été ici
examinée au Sénat nous avions intégré la
problématique de la sécheresse et plus
particulièrement du retrait gonflement
des sols argileux avec un impact
extrêmement négatif pour les maisons des
particuliers
l'année dernière nous avons examiné une
pâle copie de venant de l'Assemblée
nationale de la proposition de loi qui
était la mienne mais le problème reste
entier puisque cette problématique du
retrait gonflement des sols argileux n'a
absolument pas été intégré dans le texte
et selon d'ailleurs certains experts
cela représente une véritable bombe
sociale puisque c'est plus de la moitié
des Français qui sont concernés par
cette problématique puisque le
seul métropolitain est ainsi fait qu'il
y a plus de 60% des terres qui sont des
terres argileuses donc je voulais savoir
et d'ailleurs par rapport à la
sécheresse de cet été je vérifiais dans
mon département
un nombre très important de dossiers de
reconnaissance en quatre nattes qui
remontent concernant cette problématique
de sécheresse et donc de maison dite
fissurée comme on les appelle qui sont
le désespoir de nombre de citoyens donc
je voudrais savoir si vous souhaitez
reprendre ce dossier vous impliquez dans
ce dossier pour essayer d'apporter des
vraies réponses qui jusqu'à présent
n'ont pas été importants merci pour
votre réponse merci Jean-Claude
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre alors
finalement vous avez répondu à ma
question ma question concernait le fond
vert et moi je me réjouis que vous ayez
donné la réponse par rapport aux
modalités d'attribution qui relèvent du
bon sens deuxième sujet que vous avez
évoqué c'est la question des petites
communes il faut traiter je pense que là
aussi on vous aidera et à trouver le bon
sens pour considérer les petites
communes ce que vous avez dit sur ce que
vous avez indiqué sur des réserves voilà
qui seraient pas sûr de cibler sur des
parcelles mais à disposition des
territoires à mon avis et la bonne
solution pour dédramatiser la question
puisque la question en la posant avec le
mot zan on a vraiment affolé les
campagnes si on avait parlé de sobriété
foncières ça serait mieux passé voilà
c'était juste donc une remarque
merci Roland Dantec oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre
de deux points le premier rapide donc on
a bien compris que sur les les grandes
politiques de transition il y avait un
secrétariat général à Matignon qui
vivait coordonner entre le pilier la
transition écologique et la transition
énergétique mais sur les coques on est
on est dans un moment sur les cas pour
on a plutôt une convergence des
différentes comme biodiversité comme
climat et comme desertification la
troisième qu'on oublie tout le temps de
ce que je comprends le ministre
entre guillemets leader chef de fil et
différent d'une COP à l'autre donc
plutôt Agnès sur la COP climat et donc
Christophe BECHU sur la communauté alors
la troisième je ne sais plus où elle est
je sais pas si elle est restée au MAE
elle est peut-être au développement on
est peut-être chez toi je ne sais pas où
aller où elle est partie où elle est
chez personne mais donc on a à la fois
les multiplications des discours de
l'ONU pour dire il faut une convergence
des écope et nous on a éclaté les les
suivis ministériels alors la
coordination est où mais ça c'est une
question qui sera pas longue
savoir qui comment ce corps donne
finalement au moment où les cops essayer
de converger avec des ponts évident ne
serait-ce que sur le financement climat
pour la biodivers enfin on voit bien que
les coques doivent discuter entre elles
mon autre question est un peu plus
concerne justement les finances on
comprend bien qu'un ministre dans son
boulot il y a géré les injonctions
contradictoires
je sais pas par exemple on est le
ministre de la biodiversité là pour
préserver les espèces mais ici là il est
bien obligé d'ouvrir la chasse à une
espèce en danger en sachant que le
Conseil d'État 48 heures après qu'elle
sera l'arrêté ça fait partie du boulot
je ne demande aucune réponse sur ce
point précis mais on a une injonction
contradictoire beaucoup plus
importantes qui est au niveau financier
et c'était la présentation du ministre
dans son introduction
ce qu'on demande en termes de transition
de rénovation de développement des
ingénierie locale ne rentre pas dans le
cadre budgétaire classique
et comme on est un peu en économie de
guerre généralement en période économie
de guerre on fait du déficit c'est ainsi
que ça se passe si on veut rattraper en
d'un temps record ce qu'on n'a pas fait
sur les 20-30 années qui précèdent or la
12 musique de Bercy qui elle n'a pas
changé qui n'est pas rentré en économie
de guerre et de dire attention il faut
revenir à l'orthodoxie financière on a
déjà beaucoup dépensé par le covid
c'est fini on sera à l'euro près c'est
totalement contradictoire il est
absolument impossible de tenir les
objectifs de la transition énergétique
écologique au niveau des territoires
dans le cadre de l'orthodoxie financière
classique rien que la ville de Nantes
puisqu'on parle de 2 milliards de fond
vert la ville de Nantes c'est un
milliard rien de la rénovation des
bâtiments publics ça donne une idée de
quand même des échelles donc ma question
monsieur le ministre puisque vous avez
parlé de cette idée de budget vert
est-ce que le travail avec les réseaux
de collectivités sur les budgets verts
peut ouvrir sur des calculs
d'endettement différents on en a déjà un
peu parlé qui permettrait d'aller plus
vite
pour tenir les grands objectifs de la
transition
sans que le jour du
débat sur le budget sur le dôme
l'opposition quelle qu'elle soit un
agonise la majorité quelle qu'elle soit
en disant vous faites n'importe quoi en
terme de taux d'endettement cette
question est absolument centrale et
recoupe du coup une autre question qui
est que c'est évidemment des questions
d'investissement mais c'est aussi des
questions de fonctionnement sur
l'ingénierie et du dernier échange avec
madame la Première ministre il m'a
semblé quand même que l'ouverture du
fond vert a des crédits d'ingénierie
donc de fonctionnement était sur la
table et là j'espère beaucoup la réponse
merci Jacques Fernique oui alors à 7h je
vais pas prendre toutes les questions de
j'envisagé de poser j'aime me concentrer
sur une seule si on est évidemment
d'accord sur les trajectoires visées
pour la les parts modales voyageurs fret
pour le ferroviaire donc doublement à
l'horizon 2030 ce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est la compatibilité
comment ça peut être compatible avec la
trajectoire que vous envisagez pour les
pH ferroviaires pour les péages
ferroviaires
ce que prévoit le contrat de performance
c'est entre 2021 et 2030 arrivée à une
augmentation globale sur la période de
55% de CPH vous avez évoqué donc on a
parlé du de la difficulté du de la
quantité d'investissement nécessaire
pour le ce fameux New Deal ferroviaire
on attend le COI d'accord mais ce qu'il
faut bien en avoir en tête c'est que les
2,8 milliards d'investissements des SNCF
réseau annuel c'est surtout des fonds
propres SNCF réseau c'est à dire pour
une bonne part ce qui provient des
recettes de ces péages or est-ce que
c'est pas complètement contradictoire
comment est-ce qu'on peut réussir ou
parliez tout à l'heure de nos réseaux
Express métropolitain comment on peut
réussir le développement de nos TER nos
pendulaires de proximité par le
ferroviaire avec des perspectives
d'augmentation des péages de cet ordre
là alors j'espère que la loi de
programmation fleurie annuelle de
développement du ferroviaire qu'on
envisage et dont on parle
reposera sur quelque chose qui sera
autre que simplement la hausse
contre-productive des péages
ferroviaires
merci enfin dernière question de Nice
Saint-Pé
Président je prends le micro pour que
vous puissiez me voir tous deux merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci madame la
ministre pour votre présence ce ne
seront pas des questions mais de grosses
interrogations que j'ai et j'ai envie de
vous dire j'ai envie que vous les
transformiez en point de vigilance de
l'État alors ça concerne la desserte du
numérique madame la ministre vous nous
en avez parlé et effectivement vous avez
raison de nous dire que le développement
des des technologies satellitaires c'est
ce que l'on sait être le dernier recours
dans le monde de très rural c'est très
bien ces technologies existent mais j'ai
envie quand même de vous dire soyez
vigilants et soyez vigilants là-dessus
pourquoi pour avoir moi-même utilisé ces
technologies satellitaires parce que je
ne pouvais pas utiliser d'autres moyens
de desserte ces technologies sont très
sensibles aux coupures d'électricité
quand il y a une coupure d'électricité
vous déprogrammez tous vos appareils
donc il faut de nouveau reprogrammer etc
nous savons tous alors peut-être pas
cette année mais nous savons tous qu'au
moins à partir de l'année prochaine nous
vivrons dans notre pays des blackout des
coupures d'électricité voilà je crois
qu'il faut être nous sommes des gens
réalistes dont moi j'essaye d'être très
réaliste donc il faudra être vigilant à
ce que les distributeurs d'électricité
ils auront tendance toujours à dire on
coupe dans le monde rural parce que
c'est là que ça va moins râler il y a
moins d'habitants au kilomètre carré que
si on coupe en plein cœur de ville bon
donc vous n'entendrez pas forcément
le mécontentement des gens du monde de
très très rural mais il faudra que
l'État soit vigilant à cela
avait les distributeurs d'électricité
pour que il n'accès ils ne disent pas
systématiquement on coupe le monde rural
et deuxième point de vigilance que je
souhaitais vous apporter vous vous
sensibilisez là-dessus c'est la fin du
réseau cuivre par Orange et là pour ma
part je suis très inquiète parce que la
fin du réseau cuivre c'est 2024 et il
faut absolument il faudrait je me
permets pas de dire il faut mais il
faudrait que l'État soit très vigilant
soyez très vigilant aux exigences aux
conventionnellement que l'État doit
avoir avec Orange parce que là c'est
pareil le monde très rural va être très
pénalisée parce que je sens bien orange
qui n'a plus trop les moyens financiers
nous le savons tous mais
Orange aura tendance effectivement à et
c'est le monde très rural merci pour ces
deux points d'alerte que je souhaitais
vous êtes encore une question sur
au début de l'audition vous nous avez
dit que vous étiez là pour nous donner
des raisons d'espérer donc à cette heure
tardive je ne voudrais surtout pas qu'on
travaille l'objectif je vais essayer
d'aller vite j'avais prévu donc de dire
quelques mots s'agissant de la
thématique des transports
pourquoi la thématique des transports
tout d'abord parce que vous l'avez dit
c'est le premier secteur émetteur
deuxièmement parce que la question des
mobilités est aussi au cœur des
préoccupations des territoires y compris
des territoires ruraux et des
territoires éloignés je pense même que
c'est une thématique
dont on nous fait part de manière assez
régulière sachant que le sujet est assez
complexe pour ses collectivités
troisièmement surtout c'est le secteur
dans lequel et bien on peut intervenir
il y a des possibles c'est pas toujours
facile mais je pense que sur le secteur
des transports on peut intervenir alors
une remarque peut-être au départ c'est
que on dise premier secteur émetteur je
me méfie toujours lorsque j'utilise
cette formulation pour une raison très
simple
c'est que c'est le premier secteur
émetteur moins en raison de ce que nous
ne faisons pas qu'en raison de ce que
nous faisons autrement dit si nos
politiques publiques étaient plus
ambitieuses il est vraisemblable que le
secteur des transports serait moins
émetteur et moins négatif
environnementalement qu'il ne les
aujourd'hui et de ce point de vue il me
semble qu'on devrait conforter plus
encore et mieux nos autorités
organisatrices de mobilité
toutes les autorités organisatrices de
mobilité sans oublier les régions je dis
ça pourquoi parce qu'on a privilégié la
prise de compétences par les
collectivités de base
certaines ont pris la compétence
mobilité d'autres ne l'ont pas fait
et lorsque la collectivité de base ne la
prend pas il revient la région de le
faire
ce qui veut dire que
l'échelon institutionnel chargé de bâtir
la stratégie est aussi l'échelon auquel
on demande de boucher les trous passer
moi l'expression
et définir une politique stratégique
cohérente en bouchant des trous c'est
pas facile c'est même très complexe je
vous fais grâce ici des illustrations
que nous avons quand à la situation de
crise que traverse nos transports on les
vit tous je prendrai quand même le
transport scolaire c'est souvent des
retraités etc qui le font comment ne pas
le comprendre à 4500 450 euros par mois
par mois il va sans dire que ça ne peut
pas constiper un objectif ambitieux et
on peut comprendre que l'on rencontre
aujourd'hui des difficultés de
recrutement et autres par conséquent je
pense qu'il faut conforter ces autorités
organisatrice de transport je pense
aussi que c'est la condition pour mieux
développer des transports urbains
collectifs et c'est aussi la condition
me semble-t-il
pour enclencher un processus qui
permettrait de mettre en place le
développement du covoiturage je pense
aux zones d'emploi aux zones
relativement éloignées pas forcément
concentré et donc je pense qu'il faut
conforter mieux ces autorités
organisatrices quelle qu'elle soit sans
oublier les régions
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas y compris
à l'issue pendant la crise covid la
région Île-de-France a pu en grimper un
peu passer bonne expression mais ça
n'avait pas été le cas pour tous des
régions de France
il faut également une ambition publique
pour développer les infrastructures
ferroviaires et je pense que nous avons
besoin d'une autre ambition un petit
défaut ou un petit risque nous guette
à savoir le désenbatement tel qu'on soit
parfois je ne vous prête pas de
mauvaises intentions nullement mais on
ne peut pas envisager le traitement en
interdisant l'entreprise ferroviaire de
se développer
c'est à dire lorsqu'on conçoit le
désencatement il faut en même temps
penser le développement je pense que
sinon on va tout droit dans le mur nous
avons besoin d'une autre ambition et la
plus terrible illustration je me permets
de lui dire ici que nous en avons c'est
quand même le contrat de performance
qui n'est pas au niveau je vais je
m'arrête mais contrainte performance si
je l'applique en terme clair pour un
territoire que je connais bien la
Bretagne je vous donne une information
la Bretagne commence à Rennes pour
s'arrêter à Rennes ce qui n'est pas tout
à fait le cas voilà merci de votre
réponse merci
à Nantes je veux dire tout va bien
c'était juste une spéciale dédicace pour
Renan Dantec qui lui rappellera d'autres
échanges
ça n'a pas besoin d'être au compte-rendu
bref
alors
les pellets
la première ministre s'est engagée à
faire en sorte que les chèques énergie
permettent de couvrir les dépenses des
pellets ça rappellera certains des
amendements qui avaient été déposés dans
le cadre du PLF mais
dans le PLF qui vous sera présenté qui a
été présenté ce matin en conseiller des
ministres ou le chèque énergie arrive je
pense que des allers-retours en termes
d'amendements permettront cette fois-ci
de rendre effectif les choses et je
parle pas d'amendement de l'opposition
je pense effectivement la position du
gouvernement n'est juste en train de
finaliser les critères le machin mais
bien c'est bien l'idée de ne pas avoir
les oubliés des pellets dans le dans le
dispositif alors même qu'on a aidé les
gens à abandonner leur chaudière fioul
et qu'elle a mis du 11 parle on les aide
à remplir la chaudière quand les a aidé
à abandonner mais on ne les aide pas à
remplir la chaudière qu'on leur a aidé à
acheter donc il y a une cohérence à
laquelle nous allons revenir je vous
avoue que sur le mécanisme de fixation
des marges
des fabricants ou des importateurs de
pellets vous avez touché les limites de
mes compétences
certaines des limites de mes compétences
je ne sais pas répondre au sujet de
savoir si on a des surges des surentes
etc mais je vais me renseigner sur la
dame
ça ne m'avait pas du tout échappé
monsieur le membre du conseil
d'administration de l'ADEME compte tenu
à la fois du siège et qui est arrangé et
des liens étroits par définition que
j'ai donc pu avoir avec une partie des
prédécesseurs d'Arnaud Leroy il ne vous
a pas échappé qu'en fait un petit
élément de complexité c'est que nous
cherchons et un président et un
directeur
les deux
que la question de savoir s'il s'agit
d'un président directeur général ou d'un
président et d'un directeur général ou
d'un président directeur général et d'un
directeur général délégué ajoute une
petite inconnue dans l'équation
néanmoins nous approchons évidemment de
la fumée blanche
en ce qui concerne le PLF
et votre question sur les aides
publiques qui pourraient être
conditionné à des engagements
climatiques à court terme
nous soutenons dans le cadre de la
directive européenne
utodilidi James le fait de pouvoir lier
la performance environnementale avec le
niveau de bonus auquel les patrons en ré
droit à une échelle européenne parce
qu'on pense que autant sur les
entreprises publiques on a la main et
vous avez rappelé que ça avait été fait
autant sur des entreprises qui ne sont
pas publiques on pense qu'on a intérêt à
pousser des sujets à une échelle
européenne parce que c'est souvent la
taille
d'entreprise qui sollicite des aides ou
à partir d'une certaine taille et que ce
serait à ce niveau que ça vaudrait le
coup qu'on obtienne des choses et donc
la France pousse dans le cadre de Dieu
tout division ce que nous ayons une
règle de ce type à cette échelle
sur le retrait gonflement d'argile
le Conseil des ministres du 12 octobre a
arrêté une
une ordonnance qui tient compte de la
loi climat et résignant sur le sujet et
qui précise un certain nombre de règles
c'est pas le l'alpha et l'oméga de tout
mais ça tient bien compte effectivement
de l'été qu'on a vécu ça simplifie un
certain nombre de choses c'est Olivier
Klein au titre du ministère du logement
qui porte à l'intérieur du pôle
ministériel global
ces sujets votre réflexion sur les
catastrophes naturelles et juste le
niveau des dépenses au titre de ces
catastrophes naturelles ne cesse
d'augmenter
et ça doit être une incitation à agir
pas seulement en cassant le thermomètre
c'est à dire modifiant la prise en
charge par l'État des catastrophes
naturelles mais assumer les coûts de
l'adaptation
en ce qui concerne
la question des cops
vous avez très bien résumé les choses
pour la COP15 et la coque 2027 et pour
les autres
la Coop Ramsar sur les zones humides ou
sur le commerce international d'espèces
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de
sujets le ministère de la transition
écologique qui est de manière
systématique c'est juste parfois la
question du lead qui se pose et la
coordination et les systématiquement au
niveau du ministère des Affaires
étrangères y compris pour la COP 27 sur
laquelle il y a des enjeux qui dépassent
chacun des ministères
sur l'endettement
je vais dire les choses en fait je vais
arriver au même point que vous mais de
manière différente
je pense qu'il faut qu'on s'autorise à
sortir du cadre
du classicisme budgétaire pour régler
une partie du problème
de la hauteur des investissements
climatiques
je m'explique
la rénovation est sans doute le meilleur
sujet
il y a des domaines dans lesquels il
faut de l'argent public et dans quel il
n'y a pas de retour sur investissement
monétaire à espérer mais il y a des
retours sur investissement climatique
qui sont considérables et qui justifient
qu'on mettent l'argent et c'est ce que
je vais vous dire pour le ferroviaire
dans un instant
il y a des domaines dans lesquels il y a
déjà une équation budgétaire
et utiliser l'argent des contribuables
si il y a déjà des modèles qui
permettent de les sortir de financement
budgétaire c'est de bonne politique
je pense qu'on a des exemples à prendre
sur d'autres pays c'est ce que ces
derniers mois m'ont appris quand je
regarde les stratégies de financement
certains pays utilisent l'orchestre des
dépôts et consignations pour financer
des mesures que nous finançons à l'heure
actuelle d'un point de vue budgétaire
la nationalisation en Allemagne d'un
énergéticien elle passe par l'orchester
des dépôts kW et pas par le budget
fédéral
ce qui vous permet d'un point de vue
Maastrichtien de garder des moyens pour
agir de façon différente
je crois au modèle de l'économie mixte
pour prendre le relais d'une partie de
ce qui serait des investissements qui
sortent des ratios
et nous travaillons à une modification
du code de la commande publique
pour que les collectivités locales et
l'État puissent bénéficier du dispositif
de tir financement en matière de
rénovation parce que les sommes dont on
parle on peut se faire plaisir en
alignant les milliards mais ce n'est pas
l'échelle
les mètres carrés publiques en France
c'est entre 400 et 500 millions de
mètres carrés
ce qui veut dire que pour un coût de
rénovation à 1000 euros qui n'est pas
dans la fourchette haute
ça n'est pas le fait de voter 10
milliards d'euros ou 5 ou 8 ou 12 ou 20
ou 30 qui règle le problème
c'est le fait d'avoir potentiellement
l'ambition
de se dire qu'on change le mode de
financement si on considère qu'il est
souhaitable parce que sinon tous les
calculs font mal à la tête sur le nombre
d'années qu'il faut pour arriver à la
décarbonation du parc
il faut qu'on explore des modes
différents moins invasif et sans doute
moins coûteux et je pense qu'il y a des
promesses dans le géostockage ou la
géothermie qu'on n'a pas totalement
exploité qu'on va faire en sorte
d'exploiter de manière démonstrative sur
le site du ministère puisque je
m'apprête à lancer un appel d'offres
pour décarboner l'hôtel de rocklore qui
concentre toutes les difficultés qu'un
architecte des Bâtiments de France
pourrait adorer et voir depuis le double
vitrage en passant par l'impossibilité
d'isolation par l'extérieur
mais la capacité à utiliser la
géothermie je pense vraiment qu'elle
mérite d'être
j'allais dire creuser mais c'est un
mauvais jeu de mots mais il est tard
exploré
en revanche la modification du code de
la commande publique qui permet d'aller
faire du financement précompté en se
remboursant sur les factures me semble
prometteuses pour éviter des scandales
de PPP on peut imaginer que on monte les
opérateurs publics qui nous permettent
d'aller porter ces investissements je
reviens à mes SPL on peut imaginer des
scènes et on peut imaginer la galaxie de
la case des dépôts et consignations qui
est capable de bouger et là vous pouvez
avoir des ambitions qui vont beaucoup
plus vite pour aller avoir géré à une
échelle territoriale sur un parc de
candélabre quand vous avez géré votre
collectivité et dégager de l'épargne
comme vous pouvez sortir l'argent c'est
bien mais les 50 millions d'euros qu'on
a mis uniquement pour changer 30000
lampadaires de l'agglomération angevine
ce qui va nous permettre de diminuer de
70% de factures avant les détecteurs de
présence et d'autres dispositifs de ce
type il faut avoir la ressource
financière et on peut pas attendre des
collectivités qu'elles aient la
ressource pour faire des choses qui sont
bonnes pour le climat et qui sont bonnes
pour le porte-monnaie donc je plaide
très concrètement pour que
sur les péages ferroviaires la question
est à prendre avec le New Deal
ferroviaire global je reviens à la
manière dont les choses ont été dites
il y a deux idées fausses la première
c'est je vais nuancer mon propos
le plus important pour permettre le
report modal
avant le prix c'est l'offre
là où on a le meilleur transport en
commun c'est pas là où il est le moins
cher c'est là où il y en a le plus et
les meilleurs exemples ces lions et
Strasbourg en terme de taux d'usage et
ce sont pas des endroits où le transport
est peu cher
il y a au contraire des recettes usagées
importantes qui sont parmi les plus
élevés de France n'ont pas en montant
par individu mais en taux de couverture
du budget moyen et qui permettent de
continuer à investir donc le sujet qu'on
a sur le ferroviaire il est d'abord
celui de l'offre de l'infrastructure de
la ponctualité du nom de train des
fréquences avec des choses simples qui
coûtent des milliards d'euros comme le
rTMS qui permet à sillon constant
d'augmenter le nombre de trains que vous
pouvez mettre et qui peut nous permettre
d'aller faire du transport international
sur un certain nombre de sujets et ça
nous sommes très en retard c'est des
milliards d'euros qu'il faut qu'on soit
capable de sortir il y a aussi des
sujets sur le fret
sur le fret le coût d'adaptation pour
avoir un dispositif européen qui
permette d'avoir des wagons qui
communiquent entre eux et qui évitent
d'avoir des opérations de manutention
c'est aussi un levier pour faire en
sorte de doubler la part du Fred vous
avez produit ici au Sénat un excellent
rapport sur la manière dont les doubler
l'ambition du fret qui est de très
grande qualité et qui attend aujourd'hui
sur les étagères qu'on qu'il puisse être
pris sur une partie de ces éléments
quand on aura cette feuille de route
globale et des questions qui sont moins
ferroviaires que d'aménagement du
territoire puisqu'on a des sujets sur
les plateformes qui sont embranchés et
qui doit faire une taille suffisante
pour pouvoir stocker suffisamment de
containers pour ensuite utiliser les
sillons aux horaires disponibles donc la
question des péages c'est un des
éléments mais un des éléments au milieu
du reste parce que c'est la question du
coup mais qui questionne le niveau
d'investissement que nous demanderons de
porter à la SNCF et à riso ferrée de
France et la partie qui sera
potentiellement portée par l'État dans
le cadre du dispositif et du nudil dont
on parlait et je vous demande d'avoir
une approche globale le moment venu
et donc on va terminer sur une espérance
puisque vous m'y avait incité votre
propos est très juste sur les autorités
organisatrices de mobilité qu'il faut
qu'on soit capable d'aider pas n'importe
comment et pas en déshabillant les unes
pour alimenter les autres je ne pense
que le VM à l'échelle des interco il est
nécessaire je pense même mais c'est une
réflexion personnelle que de la même
manière qu'il existe des strates dans le
VM en fonction du niveau de l'offre que
vous remplissez le fait de mettre en
place une ZF
représente une strate et un niveau
d'engagement complémentaire qui pourrait
nécessiter ou permettre d'avoir des
moyens complémentaires pour développer
les transports en commun parce que c'est
aussi un des moyens de faire en sorte
d'améliorer les choses mais là aussi il
faut qu'on s'autorise à aller très loin
j'ai plein d'idées on verra jusqu'où on
atterrit mais bref
le mot de la fin parce qu'on reprendra
ses propos
notre pays ne pèse que 0,9% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
l'échelle mondiale
on doit agir au quotidien comme si 100%
de la situation du réchauffement
climatique dépendait de nous
mais se rappeler aussi que la partie de
diplomatie environnementale elle est
juste nécessaire parce que plus on
conduira des ruptures dans un certain
nombre de sujets
plus il faudrait pas que nos concitoyens
disent comment se fait-il que le
réchauffement climatique se soit pas
arrêté alors qu'on roule tous elle
électrique qu'on leur qu'on a modifié
teloter l'élément et ça ça suppose de
tenir un discours qui se fait un
discours responsable
responsable qui ne parle pas d'inaction
climatique quand il y a une action
climatique de notre pays
il n'y a que 20 pays dans le monde qu'on
commençait à baisser de leurs émissions
nous en faisons partie ça n'est pas
glorieux parce qu'on n'est pas au bon
rythme mais il faut pas les raconter des
histoires en français en le faisant
croire qu'on a rien fait parce que tous
ceux qui ont commencé à faire des
efforts si on leur dit que ça ou rien
c'est pareil bah on les perdra dans
l'équipe de l'écologie
il faut bien mesurer que sur des sujets
comme cela l'adhésion des gens n'est pas
un petit sujet
parce que sinon on perd le temps qu'on
pensait gagner et ça a été le cas avec
la trajectoire carbone qui était
sûrement très intelligente mais qui a
juste oublié de se demander si c'était
socialement supportable et si c'était
territorialement juste et donc fort de
ça on a
à avoir une vigilance supplémentaire sur
ces différents sujets pour agir ça
suppose le dialogue l'Union des énergies
celle des collectivités celle de la
Haute Assemblée je me réjouis qu'en
ayant passé un peu beaucoup de temps
avec vous cet après-midi nous ayons
commencé en tout cas à pouvoir balayer
une partie de ces sujets et je ne doute
pas qu'on aura des occasions d'entrer
dans le détail de tout ça au fur et à
mesure des prochaines auditions ou texte
sur lesquels nous retrouverons
très bien merci Monsieur ministre merci
madame la secrétaire d'État